Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt,
es ist der fünfzehnte Januar zwanzig einundzwanzig und es ist Freitag und es heißt es ist wieder Zeit für Corona Wickly mit mir, Tim Brit Dav und mit Pavel, Pavel Meier, hallo Pavel.
Ja, eine weitere Woche ist ins Land gegangen, von der man wahrscheinlich jetzt schon mal sagen kann,
So viel besser ist es jetzt irgendwie noch nicht geworden. Wir wollen wie immer hier ein wenig die Zahlen zusammentragen und interpretieren und mal
was ich eigentlich im Rahmen der Corona Krise vorzugsweise in Deutschland, aber auch sonst so in der Welt noch getan hat.
Haben ein paar Nachrichten rund um die ganze Impferei und äh viele offene Fragen, glaube ich, zu dem wir vielleicht auch nicht alle Antworten haben. Mal schauen.
Wie ist bei dir so gelaufen in der Woche.
Ja ja geht so.
Man hat sich irgendwie so ein bisschen arrangiert, ne, mit dem es passiert ja eigentlich nichts, also.
Ja, also es ich, also ich finde es schlägt schon ganz schön aufs Gemüt das Ganze und vor allen Dingen,
halt auch sich dann immer wieder äh zu versuchen irgendwie hochzuziehen mit der Aussicht, dass dann irgendwann in sechs Monaten vielleicht äh ja äh alles ein bisschen entspannter ist das.
Das Feld schwer.
Fällt schwer, aber geht ja auch nicht anders. Ich äh halte den Optimismus hoch, wenn's auch nur dadurch ist, dass ich mir von vorne rein schon gesagt habe, na ja, bis Ende März.
Vierzig eh nicht viel verbessert haben und das ist so ein bisschen meine persönliche Hoffnung, dass wir im zweiten Quartal.
Perspektiven erkennen können, wo es äh vielleicht hingehen könnte mit diesem Jahr.
Ja und ich sage mal alle Hoffnung ist noch nicht verloren, es könnte ja auch sein, dass es irgendwie noch äh ja vernünftige Entscheidungen gibt, die dann auch.
Ja uns auf einen Weg bringen.
Der uns schneller zum Ziel führt. Ja so, das würde ich jetzt nicht vollkommen ausschließen wollen.
Genau, es gibt auch zahlreiche Initiativen, die werden wir auch noch im weiteren besprechen, aber ich würde äh vorschlagen, wie immer fangen wir mal an mit den aktuellen Zahlen, wie sieht's denn aus, Pavel.
Die Zahlen haben eine ziemliche Achterbahnfahrt gemacht in den letzten vier, fünf Wochen, so es ging,
wild drauf, dann wieder wild runter, dann wieder rauf und jetzt geht's in den letzten Tagen wieder leicht runter und im Ergebnis äh liegen wir jetzt auf einem Niveau,
bei den Neuinfektionen,
wie Anfang Dezember oder Ende November sogar. So, das heißt, wir haben uns jetzt seit.
Über zwei Monaten, zweieinhalb Monaten ungefähr seitwärts bewegt im Effekt. Die Zahlen sind nicht wesentlich nach oben, also die täglichen Neuinfektionen.
Aber auch nicht nach unten gegangen. Der Lokdown hat also zwar gewirkt aber halt nicht genug,
so und da er auch zu spät gekommen ist äh so sind die Zahlen die ganze Zeit auf einem zu hohen Niveau, was dazu geführt hat, dass wir garnen weiterhin ein Höchstniveau,
an Toten leider zu verzeichnen haben. So das ist halt,
wir liegen jetzt so fast bei neunhunder.
Im sieben Tagesschnitt seit einer Woche. Ja.
Und das ist schon heftig. Ähm.
Eine echte Kuriosität, aber ist mir aufgefallen, die man jetzt nicht vermuten würde, äh was jetzt durch die Weihnachtszeit passiert ist,
und das Treffen jetzt mehrere Effekte zusammen, die so einen Zahlenchaos jetzt verursacht haben,
Das eine ist, dass halt die Testzahlen extrem eingebrochen sind, so zwei Wochen lang.
Fast dann im Endeffekt sich halbiert haben.
Um dann wieder um dreißig Prozent nach oben äh zu gehen. So.
Und dadurch äh sind, das kann man dann ganz schön am Grafen äh sehen, wenn man mal die prozentualen Veränderungen sich.
Anschaut äh bei,
der Zahl der Tests, bei der Zahl der positiven Tests und bei der positiven Quote, dann ist es so, dass normalerweise also fast seit Beginn der Infektion, kann man sagen, folgt,
die ähm,
positiven Quote äh der Zahl der positiven Tests. Also sie sind hauptsächlich korrigiert. Das heißt, geht die, geht die Zahl der positiven Tests nach oben, geht auch die positiven Rate nach oben und umgekehr.
Jetzt in den letzten drei Wochen hat sich dieser Effekt komplett umgedreht. Das heißt,
die Zahl der positiven Tests folgt der Zahl der Tests, das heißt es hat sich bei den Infektionen nicht wirklich was getan, obwohl die Zahlen halt rauf und runter gegangen sind, äh die Testzahlen und die positiven Quote und äh die.
Positiven Zahlen alles hat halt wild geschwankt, aber im Grunde genommen hat sich an der Infektionsfront gar nichts getan. Das war also,
sagenden künstlicher Sturmen, der einfach die Erfassung komplett durcheinander gebracht hat, wie wenn man so ein Messgerät hat, so ein Salzmometer und tritt da einmal dagegen. Ähm.
Aber was noch bizarrer ist, dass wir,
über vierzehn Tage lang und zwar von äh im Prinzip nach Weihnachten beginnend bis so in den.
Achten neunten Januar hinein. Ebenfalls einen Rückgang bei der Zahl der Toten hatten.
Da kann man genau sehen, wenn man irgendwie die Linie durchziehen würde, ist da plötzlich halt so eine so eine Lücke, wo,
ist plötzlich hundert Tote weniger am Tag sind, für vierzehn Tage und dann zack geht's wieder hoch auf einmal auf einen Wert.
Den es genommen hätte, wenn das einfach weiter mehr oder weniger gerade gestiegen wäre. Was heißt, dass wir ungefähr in in den vierzehn Tagen so um die tausendfünfhundert Tote.
Weniger in der Statistik hatten, aber kann sehr stark davon ausgehen, dass,
die ja Leute nicht plötzlich nur weil Weihnachten es aufgehört haben zu sterben für vierzehn Tage und dann äh äh wieder nachgelegt haben so. Und,
könnte jetzt erstmal denken, na ja gut, da ist halt nicht so schnell gezählt worden, da kommt dann halt,
irgendwann die Nachmeldungen, da kommt sozusagen dann irgendwann der Berg nach und ein bisschen ist da sicherlich auch nachgekommen, genauso wie bei der Zahl der Neuinfektionen
aber mitnichten äh sind,
alle Toten oder alle Infektionen, die da nicht gezählt worden sind, jetzt irgendwann nachgekommen, sondern die sind einfach unter den Tisch gefallen.
Also eine Untererfassung der Sterbezahlen.
Ja eine eine Unterfassung der Sterbezahlen sogar über über Weihnachten und,
überlegen, okay, wie kann das jetzt sein? Und da ist,
schon wahrscheinlich, dass äh ja viele Leute einfach es gar nicht bis ins Krankenhaus oder bis zum Test geschafft haben.
Und dass man außerdem dann ja, es ist nach wie vor nicht üblich, wenn jemand verstirbt, immer einen Coronatest äh zu machen. Das ähm.
Ja und das ist dann wohl über Weihnachten wohl unterblieben.
Das ließe sich eigentlich erst im Nachhinein wieder herausrechnen, wenn man das eben so mit den durchschnittlichen Sterbezahlen vielleicht vergleicht.
Aus den Gesamtsterbezahlen, wenn man dann, wenn wir die Sterbezahlen haben, dann können wir sehen, ob's auch bei den Sterbezahlen äh äh vierzehn Tage langen Einbruch gibt, was sich für sehr unwahrscheinlich halte.
Aber das ist so die aktuelle Zahlensituation.
Mit Ausblick, ja, man weiß es nicht. So.
Sagt die Zahlen können halt sinken, gleichbleiben oder steigen.
Und ja, wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste, das wahrscheinlich ist, dass sie langsam runtergehen werden erstmal und zwar solange bis wir anfangen zu lockern, dann gehen sie wieder hoch. Das ist irgendwie.
Meine Prognose, aber es kann auch äh ja, gerade in in jede Richtung gehen. Das ist halt wirklich schwierig zu sagen.
Genau, insbesondere, wenn man sich die Entwicklung jetzt in manchen Nachbarländern anschaut, äh also im erweiterten Sinne Nachbarländer. Wir haben da extrem hohe äh Steigungsraten in manchen Ländern, Irland.
UK, Dänemark.
Was viel jetzt dieser neuen Virusvariante zugeschrieben wird, was ja auch äh kräftig in der Diskussion ist, werden wir sicherlich auch nochmal drüber reden.
Und äh da jetzt in zunehmendem Maße diese und andere Virusvarianten, auch diese Südafrika Virusvariante hier und da in Deutschland auch nachgewiesen wird
teilweise bei Einreisenden, wo man nicht weiß, haben die das jetzt irgendwie reingetragen. Aber ich glaube, das äh man kann einfach mal getrost davon ausgehen,
dass sich diese Virusvariante auch in Deutschland verbreiten wird, wenn nicht.
Eingetragen, kann sie sich genauso gut auch herausbilden, so wie sie das jetzt in verschiedenen Ländern ja unabhängig voneinander getan hat, das war also in zunehmendem Maße mit Mutationen.
Uns auseinandersetzen müssen, die eben unter Umständen, die Infiziosität nochmal nach oben treibt und dann reichen unsere Maßnahmen sowieso nicht aus.
Also Dänemark hat ja so angefangen auch recht schnell dann,
zu testen, wie hoch denn der Anteil ist der neuen Virus Variante und das ging dann so los, so null Komma zwei Prozent.
Null Komma vier Prozent, null Komma acht Prozent, äh eins Komma sechs Prozent ähm ja und als sie plötzlich, also sie hatten dann innerhalb von äh.
Wenigen.
Tagen glaube ich äh äh waren das äh stellten sie fest, äh dass äh sie dann plötzlich auf drei Prozent bereits waren von.
So gut wie nichts und war klar, wenn wir jetzt nicht irgendwas tun, dann äh dauert es äh nur Wochen und diese neue Virusvariante wird.
Die verbreitet im Land sein und deswegen sind die wie ich in einem ziemlich harten Loktor gegangen und da sind die Zahlen gerade auch massiv im Sinkflug in Dänemark.
Auch in Irland, auch in Tschechien, also es schaue jetzt gerade nochmal auf die aktuelle Case äh Entwicklung, also im Großen und Ganzen.
Scheint gerade nichts so richtig loszufliegen, also alles wo es äh Out of Control war ähm haben härtere Maßnahmen jetzt ein bisschen äh gegriffen.
Noch so einige Länder sind weit äh über uns, was so die effektiven.
Zahlen betrifft, also relativ zur Bevölkerung, ne? Da sind wir noch lange nicht die Schlechtesten, aber.
Das könnte heute noch kommen. Tja, dann vielleicht mal Deutschland so ein bisschen äh in kleinerer Auflösung. Bundesländer nimmt sich das irgendwie was.
Ja bei den Bundesländern sieht es so aus, nachdem in den letzten Tagen,
in allen Bundesländern wir steigende Zahlen hatten, haben wir jetzt so in vier Bundesländern leicht fallende Zahlen minimal nur,
und insgesamt nivelliert sich das äh aber also die Situation beruhigt sich.
So ein bisschen äh kann man sagen, ne,
Länder liegen nicht mehr so weit auseinander, vorne liegt halt immer noch Sachsen, aber gerade die Länder,
die in den letzten Wochen noch die höchsten Zuwächse hatten, sowie Sachsen und Bayern, aber auch Baden-Württemberg.
Da sinken, äh die Zahlen gerade und.
Es ist auch wieder keine ganz klare Ostwestverteilung aber fast so Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Ist.
Auch noch mit äh ja eine hundertdreißiger Institut äh steht noch ganz okay da und ansonsten aber sind ja die äh ersten vielen seit Sachsen, Thüringen, Brandenburg.
Berlin und Sachsen-Anhalt.
So und dann kommt's noch Saarland und dann der Westen und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern sagen, stehen besser da als der Deutschlanddurchschnitt.
Ja, aber insgesamt wie gesagt alles auf nach wie vor äh hohem Niveau, aber man man merkt es tut sich gerade was, also es geht tendenziell im Moment etwas zurück.
Nur, dass ich einfach nicht ablesen lässt, wie lange das anhält, so. Das ist ein Momentaufnahme.
Also es ist erstens, wie gesagt, eine Momentaufnahme und zweitens.
Da wo Rückgänge sind die Minimal, also im sag mal unter fünf, also fünf Prozent oder drei Prozent so in der Gegend innerhalb von einer Woche.
Und das ist nix, wo man irgendwo hinkommt mit.
Ja, ist alles nicht so schön. Ähm Deutschland stellt derzeit so sechs Komma fünf Prozent aller weltweit gezählten Toten. So, das ist äh.
Ein ziemliche Hammer Nummer finde ich.
Und überhaupt obwohl das ja alles so fluktuiert du hast es schon gesagt so die Zahl der Toten steigt halt nach wie vor.
Ja? Gut, die ist seit einer Woche ungefähr ist sie jetzt ungefähr konstant äh geblieben, aber äh auf einem verdammt hohen Niveau einfach, wie gesagt.
Neunhundert pro Tag und an manchen Tagen deutlich über tausend. Das ist bitter.
Ja, was gibt's noch? Gibt's noch irgendwelche anderen Details.
Ja, was man vielleicht noch.
Sich anschauen kann ist äh Berlin wo ich ja dann mir auch immer die Institutionen auch Altersgruppe.
Mir immer selber ausrechne und plotte aus den Daten.
Und da ist eigentlich nur eine interessante Sache oder zwei interessante Sachen. Das eine ist, man sieht halt diese Weihnachtsdelle.
Überall in in allen Altersgruppen und man sieht auch, dass sozusagen die Instit ja.
Ins Tal rein runter und wieder hoch jetzt auf.
Mehr oder weniger wert bevor ja vor Weihnachten vor vier Wochen und dort jetzt einigermaßen verharrt.
Gilt für fast alle Altersgruppen, äh so wobei bei den äh über Achtzigjährigen hat man da sogar noch einen ganz leichten Anstieg.
Ähm und bei aber der Altersgruppe der fünf bis vierzehnjährigen.
Sieht man äh hat da weiter einen Tren.
Stattgefunden. Da kann man einen einfach quasi sehen, so eine Linie äh durch die Delle durchverlängern und äh sieht, dass sich seitdem,
nochmal wieder die Zahlen ja nicht ganz halbiert haben, aber äh ja nochmal um fünfzig Prozent gefallen sind.
Und das natürlich vor dem Hintergrund geschlossener Schulen äh gerade.
Woraus man denn äh schon auch nochmal schließen kann, dass äh ja.
Sagen die Hauptgruppe, die dafür sorgt, äh dass die Zahlen überhaupt einigermaßen stabil sind, äh ist die Altersgruppe der fünf bis vierzehnjährigen gerade.
Und noch interessanterweise fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzigjährigen.
Ja also im Moment geht's bei den jüngeren äh eben stärker zurück und bei den Älteren ist es gleichbleiben.
Ja ich glaube wir hatten ja letzte Woche, als wir die Sendung aufgenommen haben, gerade noch so kurz debattiert, so wie denn jetzt mit den Schulen überhaupt verfahren werden sollte. Äh zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme der Sendung hieß es noch, dass eigentlich am Montag,
Also jetzt letzten Montag die Schulen dann zumindest in Berlin wieder öffnen sollen.
Und äh während wir unsere Sendung gemacht haben, rasselten dann sozusagen die Nachrichten rein, dass sich das dann alles äh wieder umgedreht hat. Da es dann in der Politik äh ein kleines Beben,
abgefeiert worden und dann hieß es OK alles klar, wir bleiben jetzt nochmal zwei Wochen zu,
bedeutet für Berlin de facto das nach aktuellem Stand, es hieße in zwei Wochen machen sie wieder auf. Das ist dann allerdings eine Woche vor Beginn der Winterferien in Berlin.
So dass,
davon ausgehe, dass das auch noch fällt. So, ich hatte da auch so einen Elternabend, habe mal so die Klassenlehrerin angesprochen und meinte auch nur so, ich habe.
Auf die Woche kommt's dann irgendwie auch nicht mehr an, so jetzt haben wir uns irgendwie eh alle schon so auf Lokdown äh eingefahren und man merkt jetzt auch, dass das wo sie sich im,
März, April alle noch so gegen gewehrt haben, ne, mit den digitalen äh Instrumenten, den Schulunterricht durchzuführen, mit Videokonferenzen, mit äh Schulclouds und so weiter,
dass sie sich zumindest anfreunden mit der Situation. Das war,
mal ganz subjektiver anekdodischer Eindruck, den ich hier äh gewonnen habe, dass sie so sehen, so ja was äh was sollen wir uns jetzt hier alle noch nennenswert äh gefährden, jetzt
in der Woche normalen Unterricht zu machen kriegst du sowieso nicht so wieder hochgefahren und dann ist gleich nochmal eine Woche,
Pause, dann kannst du halt Adi auch gleich zu Hause bleiben, die Woche auch nochmal mitnehmen und es war also ich vermute einfach mal kurz gesagt, darauf wird's hinauslaufen, weil äh der Widerstand aus der Elternschaft relativ stark ist, zurecht.
Wie sieht denn das eigentlich aus? Gibt es eigentlich Notbetreuung? Einer der Schulen äh die du da kennst, hast du dich mal mit der Situation.
Beschäftigt.
Beschäftigt ist ein großes Wort, da ich jetzt nicht mehr die Kinder in dem Alter habe, diese jetzt so besonders betreuungsintensiv sind, habe ich da kein keine eigene Erfahrung. Das mag so sein teilweise,
meine aber auch mitbekommen zu haben, dass zumindest dann der Grundschule.
Eins meiner Kinder ist, dass da auch der Hortbetrieb, glaube ich, auch eingestellt wurde. Also ich weiß es nicht genau, um ehrlich zu sein.
Also ich habe nur nämlich mitbekommen in den letzten Woche so erstmal anekdotisch äh von jemanden, der meinte, na ja, anfangs sah es so gewesen, also dessen äh.
Mutter arbeitet im äh,
Gesundheitswesen ist halt Krankenschwester und ja hat dann deswegen äh das Kind dann in Notbetreuung gegeben in der Schule anfangs,
werden's halt nur zwei Kinder gewesen,
aber dann mittlerweile jetzt sehst du da so die halbe Klasse jeden Tag zusammen machen dann nicht wirklich Schulunterricht, aber äh sagen Notbetreuung und dann habe ich mal,
so getwittert, äh wie sieht denn das sonst so aus und die Replice waren dann.
Sehr unterschiedlich kann man sagen. Es gibt wohl tatsächlich.
Auch Schulen, wo über fünfzig Prozent, teilweise habe ich gehört von bis zu siebzig Prozent der Kinder in Notbetreuung sind, aber das sind nur weniger Ausnahmen,
er scheint so zehn bis zwanzig Prozent äh der Fall zu sein und,
Es wurde dann auch schon in den Medien und von der Politik thematisiert,
weil es gibt da Unterschiede, wer Anspruch eigentlich hat auf Notbetreuung oder nicht und da gab's dann mal Berufslisten, die wurden dann aber aufgehoben und dann überlegte man, ob man die wieder braucht, jedenfalls in Brandenburg. Also.
Das heißt, für mich war nur wichtig, okay, wenn man sich jetzt fragt
äh gut, wenn jetzt so alles zu hat, wo finden denn dann die ganze Zeit die Infektionen eigentlich überhaupt noch statt? Äh kann man sagen, da haben wir definitiv halt auch noch ein Loch äh nämlich,
ja Norden, Notbetreuung äh von äh Kindern ähm da.
Passiert vermutlich auch was zumal, dann ist wohl auch so ist, dass dann der Lehrer so dann von Klassenzimmer zu Klassenzimmer dann auch noch gibt.
Und ja man wird sehen.
Wird man sehen schwer äh abzuschätzen, was man da jetzt äh am besten tun kann.
Ja. Also sie hat sicherlich auch, ich sage mal, es hat,
sicherlich auch Grenzen. Ich meine, man kann nun mal dann wahrscheinlich Kinder in einem bestimmten Alter äh wenn man berufstätig ist, kann man nun mal nicht äh ja dann äh zu Hause äh lassen.
Zumindest bei bestimmten Berufen.
Und bei bestimmten Altersgruppen vor allem, also das,
halt so bis zur na ja zweiten, dritten, vierten Klasse ist, ist halt einfach noch erforderlich. Danach wird's äh langsam besser, andererseits will man natürlich jetzt auch, wenn man lange arbeitet
und sonst einfach wirklich niemand da ist, die Kinder nicht irgendwie acht oder zehn Stunden zu Hause äh alleine lassen. Das ist ja irgendwie auch nicht hilfreich.
Schwieriges Problem wie alle anderen Probleme auch. Dementsprechend äh mehren sich jetzt auch die Aufrufe.
Zum Thema, was für eine Strategie sollen wir denn jetzt eigentlich aufschlagen hier, was was wollen wir jetzt eigentlich tun,
Und es gab jetzt in dieser Woche, da ich eine ganze Batterie von Aufrufen, Petitionen äh.
Ja Gruppen, die sich zusammengefunden haben rund um dieses Sirokovit-Schema, ne? Wir hatten das ja auch, glaube ich, vor einigen Wochen schon mal diskutiert.
Ähm das ist ja auch eine Strategie, die eben manche Länder ja auch sehr erfolgreich.
Gegangen sind, haben wir hier auch schon mehrfach erwähnt, Neuseeland.
Ist da ganz weit vorne und Taiwan et cetera die einfach von vorne herein einfach gesagt haben,
reicht uns irgendwie nicht äh ohne Siroko wird, können wir ja irgendwie überhaupt nicht vorwärts und manchen ist es dann eben auch gut gelungen und äh anderen eben nicht so gut,
Wobei ich den Eindruck habe, die, die es wirklich von Anfang an auch angestrebt haben, sind dem auch sehr nahe gekommen. Jetzt gibt's diverse äh Initiativen äh was wir schon,
mal erwähnt, haben es die Website Endcoronavarus dort Org, die sich diesem Thema ja extrem.
Ähm annimmt, bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ihr das hier schon mal so besprochen haben.
Ähm, diese Webseiten sind eigentlich immer sehr ähnlich, die listen halt einfach verschiedene Maßnahmen auf, die man so grundsätzlich erstmal anstreben sollte als Basis aller politischen Entscheidungen.
Und ja kurz gesagt die grundlegende Kurve Zerostrategie die hier ausgerufen wird ist.
Ja, man soll halt irgendwie alle erstmal unter diesen,
Thema auch vereinigen, das ist natürlich schon mal der schwierigste Schritt. Also alle müssen sozusagen das auch als allgemeines Ziel anerkennen und jede Handlung und jede politische Entscheidung diesem Thema dann unterwerfen.
Und dann halt äh Punkt zwei.
Use des Strong des Position Action, also man soll sozusagen immer die maximale Maßnahme ergreifen, die irgendwie geht.
Das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal gehabt so und im Prinzip genau das Elend der letzten Monate in Deutschland, dass wir eigentlich erstmal gesagt haben, ja wir machen erstmal ein bisschen was. Und so ach hat nicht gereicht, ne, dann machen wir nochmal ein bisschen was,
Und damit rennst du ja der Entwicklung eigentlich immer hinterher. Ne, weil du dann immer wieder siehst, oh wir kriegen's nicht eingegrenzt, was eine weitere Ausbreitung, dann verschärfst du wieder so ein bisschen, aber mit diesen Verschärfungen kriegst du bestenfalls das, was du jetzt vorher schon verloren hast, wieder in den Griff und,
sie ist halt genau diese flache äh Entwicklungskurve, die wir jetzt seit Monaten haben.
Dann eben auch schon tausend Mal erwähnt, äh Reisebestimmung, äh Quarantäne an den Grenzen, das muss halt äh Knaller durch äh gesetzt werden, ist natürlich in Europa ein Problem, gar keine Frage.
Ja, aber vielleicht.
Äh äh da hat's dann ja vorhin auch schon mal äh kurz erwähnt, aber das Lustige ist, wenn man jetzt die aktuellen Logdown.
Den Loktor in der ersten Welle vergleicht.
Dann äh haben beide elf Wochen gedauert. Also bisher, wir sind jetzt wie in der elften Woche vom Blockdown, der am zweiten elften mit dem Lokdown Light begonnen hat und.
Der Logdown bei der ersten Ville fing halt am dreiundzwanzigsten März glaube ich an.
Das war der Montag. Ja und ging dann bis zum sechsten Juni wobei dann am schon am vierten Mai und dann am,
sechsten Juni, nur sagen, jeweils gelockert wurde, also sagen ja, elf Wochen, wobei eben tatsächlich sogar nach sechs Wochen die ersten Lockerungen da waren.
Haben wir jetzt zweiten elften angefangen, haben dann am sechzehnten zwölften äh nochmal verschärft und dann jetzt am elften Januar äh auch nochmal, ja.
Dann, wenn man sich anguckt, auch noch wann wir denn damals angefangen haben, wie denn die Zahlen aussahen? Hatten wir damals hatten wir zweitausend Fälle pro Tag.
Ja? Wenn wir jetzt zurückgehen und gucken, wann hatten wir denn in der zweiten ähm.
In der zweiten Welle jetzt die zweitausend Fälle pro Tag erreicht oder überschritten. Dann war.
Dass ähm.
Mitte Oktober.
Ende ja eher sogar wenn du genau hinguckst so bei der Zweitausender Linie ist es sogar ja Anfang Oktober sogar Ende September.
Äh auf jeden Fall hätte man nur sagt, okay, es hat dann eben plötzlich angezogen, also spätestens in der ersten Oktoberwoche, so hätte man dann,
Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen und wir haben uns den Luxus erlaubt drei oder vier Wochen.
Dem, wie man das sieht, später zu intervenieren, als wir es in der ersten Welle gemacht haben.
Und das auch noch schwächer.
Und dann haben wir halt mit Leid angefangen, festgestellt, hm äh hilft nur so ein bisschen, wir brauchen mehr äh hilft auch nur so ein bisschen, wir brauchen noch mehr. So.
Ergebnis ist aber, dass wir jetzt äh auf einem Niveau verharren seit eben.
Ja zehn Wochen äh was halt vier Mal so hoch ist wie der Gipfel der ersten Welle und da nicht nicht runterkommen.
Und im Grunde genommen ist einfach, wenn man das.
Sich diese beiden sagen unsere Handlung in der ersten Welle und unsere Handlungen in der zweiten äh Welle äh und das Ergebnis äh anschaut, dann,
kann man einfach nicht zu nichts anderem kommen als halt jetzt Zero Cove,
wobei man da dann noch ein bisschen natürlich weiterdenkt wie ja äh wie muss dann natürlich anders handeln, wenn's dann nach unten geht, wie macht man das mit den Lockerungen und so, ja ähm
Was sind denn noch so Empfehlungen wie äh also außer dass
man jetzt eigentlich so früh wie möglich so hart wie möglich äh intervenieren sollte und was dann, man kann das ja nicht ewig durchhalten.
Nee, man könnte natürlich kann man's nicht ewig durchhalten, aber es es geht ja generell immer dadrum, äh es sozusagen in einem Rahmen zu halten, ne, mit dem Ziel Sirokowit.
Selbst wenn man das nicht erreicht, dadurch, dass man das halt anstrebt
erreicht man zumindest mehr, als wenn man von vornherein sagt, man könnte jetzt irgendwelche Zahlen tolerieren, weil den Weg haben wir jetzt gerade gesehen, der funktioniert nicht.
Einfach da vornschaft noch mehr Probleme und macht jede Maßnahme danach noch schwerer als es vorher war, ne? Wie du schon gesagt hast, also hätten wir quasi jetzt Mitte Oktober einfach auch da hätte wahrscheinlich schon gereicht zu sagen
Oh, wir machen jetzt mal hier so zwei Wochen harten Lokdown. So und mit klaren Datum und dann ist auch schon wieder irgendwie vorbei.
Vorlauf bereitet euch vor oder was auch immer,
So, dann wären wir ganz woanders. Gut, das ist immer ein bisschen einfach, äh, rückblickend zu sagen, hätte man, weil ne, die Zukunft ist immer äh schwammig.
Na ja ich mein wie gesagt so schwierig also zu sagen einfach okay
wir haben da haben wir in der ersten Welle reagiert. Das machen wir jetzt einfach nochmal so, aber nee, wir machen's diesmal anders, weil das erste beim ersten Mal war ja zu erfolgreich.
Ja und es war halt auch teuer, ne? Ich meine, es
so diese diese Angst gewesen, so oh mein Gott, jetzt haben wir das letzte Mal gerade so geschafft jetzt läuft die Wirtschaft wieder so ein bisschen und in dieser Hoffnung, dass am Laufen lassen zu können und irgendwie klüger zu handeln und jetzt haben wir ja auch Masken und was nicht alles
Ja, wir haben ja so viel gelernt und äh wir können uns ja auch besser schützen.
Dass es dann eben reicht, geringer einzugreifen. Und das kann ich ein Stück weit auch nachvollziehen, aber leider hat sich halt gezeigt, funktioniert nicht.
So der BER-Effekt so ein bisschen, weil äh es war eigentlich auch so, dass eigentlich das.
Sie am BER das Dreamteam am Start hat.
Das waren alles Leute, die haben schon ohne Ende Flughäfen gebaut, äh waren wirklich hatten da die besten Leute der Welt
zusammengeholt. Haben sich dann gesagt, okay, wir haben jetzt so ein super Team
Jetzt machen wir es in drei Jahren statt in fünf Jahren wie sonst so alles läuft ja das Ergebnis kennen wir.
Ist vielleicht so vergleichbar, so ein bisschen Hybris einfacher. Wir haben das schon im Griff, wir kriegen jetzt schon hin, wir sind, wir sind schon gut, wir sind schon die Besten und wird schon werden.
Also ich hoffe, die BER Timeline wird jetzt hier nicht zur Blaupause für den weiteren Pandemieverlauf, ne.
Das will ich auch nicht hoffen, aber ich glaube äh so der Effekt, äh so ein hyberes Effekt, so hat man alles schon mal gemacht. Ja.
Punkt fünf Punkt sechs dieser allgemeinen Formulierung ist halt äh ja also man soll sich drum kümmern, dass die Leute die am meisten äh betroffen sind, natürlich auch am meisten Unterstützung bekommen,
Klar und dann natürlich schnelle äh Impfung von Leuten mit hohem Risiko.
Das gibt's jetzt schon eine Weile, das haben wir auch schon mal diskutiert, das ist so diese grundlegende äh Erkenntnis. Klingt irgendwie banal alles. Jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht, aber ist glaube ich auch mal ganz wichtig, das auch mal so aufgeschrieben zu haben,
Jetzt gibt's 'ne Initiative von Wissenschaftlerinnen in Europa.
Die sich jetzt zusammen äh getan haben und hier auch eine Website aufgesetzt haben. WWW Concontaine Covet,
Strich Pan Punkt EU. Also schon auch äh jetzt der Ansatz, die europäisch vorzugehen. Äh ist auch multilingual äh die Webseite.
Und äh ja auch hier das ist halt auch, sagen wir mal, viele bekannte Namen,
aus Deutschland dabei hier gleich zuerst Viola Priesemann, Melanie Brinkmann, Sandra Ziesig, also alles,
Personen, die man äh in der in der Debatte in Deutschland jetzt schon mehrfach dazu gehört hat und die ja auch sich dadurch auszeichnen, eigentlich immer sehr kluge Dinge von sich zu geben.
Meiner Meinung nach ja und die sagen halt auch, so niedrige Fallzahlen äh retten, leben, niedrige Fallzahlen sichern Arbeitsplätze und Unternehmen, das sagen wir mal auch so diese Argumentation.
Umdreht mit sie müssen ja die Wirtschaft weiterlaufen. Wir können ja hier nicht einfach nur uns um die Pandemie kümmern. Nee, das genau andersrum, ne? Also
wenn man das halt irgendwie sicherstellen will, muss man mit niedrigen Fallzahlen arbeiten und nur dann kann eben auch die Ausbreitung effektiver kontrolliert werden.
Denn Kontakt nach Verfolgung, Quarantäne sind bei Ruhenfallzahlen einfach nicht durchführbar,
und äh diese ganze Debatte mit äh Herdenhumanität oder überhaupt nun natürlich erworbener Immunität. Das ist halt einfach,
keine Option einfach, weil die einfach zu viele Leute sterben und so weiter, ne?
Ja, das haben mittlerweile auch alle, die es probiert haben, also UK und Schweden,
haben das halt hoch erkannt. Ich meine im, ja, im im Grunde genommen, ja, ist es auch sagen.
Ist die Sache eigentlich ganz ganz einfach. Man kann sagen, effektive Kowittbekämpfung, das habe ich sogar gemacht, eine ganze Strategie kann man in einem Tweet.
Zusammenfassen. Wenn ich sagen, solange die Zahlen nicht sinken, verschärfen, sogar die Regel.
Und das fahren wir jetzt äh nämlich im Moment äh auch.
Und solange die Zahlen nicht unten sind, wird auch nichts gelockert. So, dass wir mal so sagen, eigentlich die zwei Regeln, wenn man die befolgt, äh, so plus.
Hier wird nicht gelockert.
Maximal hart äh reingehen, ja. Ähm.
Also Alternativen gibt's da nicht und tatsächlich auch noch einen eine andere Sache.
Äh du weißt warum sich Grippe so lange hält jeweils, obwohl sie so saisonal ist.
Die Grippeviren halt dann immer von Nord zu Südhalbkugel und wieder zurückwandern.
So, deswegen kann halt Grippe trotz Sommer überleben, weil sie dann sagen im auf der Südhalbkugel überwintert. Was wir jetzt mit Kowitt machen ist.
Ein Land treibt die Zahlen runter äh und im Nachbarland äh gehen sie dann wieder hoch. So, dass das Virus halt munter, wenn's in einem Land jetzt äh gerade die Zahlen runter sind, dann äh ja,
ähm kommt's dann halt vom Nachbarland wieder rein. Und das ist ja auch ein Punkt von Zero Kovic äh noch, dass man dann äh sagen, beziehungsweise,
Konzept von Green Zones ist da gibt's ja da teilweise auch, dass man dann sagt, okay, da wo wir jetzt unten sind mit den Zahlen, da,
lockern wir dann, aber wir halten halt, wenn es in sagen benachbarte Gebiete gibt,
wo die Infektion noch grasiert, dann reduzieren wir einfach Kontakte und vergrößern quasi dann Stück für Stück die Gebiete in denen,
dann ja wenig ist, die Green Zones und bis dann hoffentlich irgendwann dann die ganze Welt eine Greenson.
Ist, was Kowit neunzehn angeht.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt gerade die Frage, äh inwiefern äh ist jetzt hier einfach langsam mal zu einer europäischen Initiative kommen müsste, also zumindest zu einer EU äh
plus X Initiative. Äh weil genau das sehen wir ja in Europa. Jetzt hatten wir in Deutschland irgendwie gute Zahlen, in Tschechien ist es irgendwie total
weggaloppiert und dann sichert's halt dann über Sachsen ein und dann fängt's im Prinzip jedes Mal wieder von vorne an.
Nach Thüringen weiter und dann ja läuft es wahrscheinlich auch wie so eine Welle äh auch noch äh möglicherweise durchs Land ähm von rechts, von links, von oben, von unten ja.
Gibt auch noch eine weitere Initiative, die ich hier äh kurz erwähnen möchte. Das ist äh jetzt ein deutscher äh Aufruf äh Zerostrich Kowit Punkt org, der kam auch gestern raus,
ist auch verbunden mit so einer Petition, die man unterschreiben kann. Die haben halt fünf Punkte,
von denen jetzt auch wieder viele Petitionen drin ist, aber ich wollte vor allem auf einen Punkt nochmal eingehen, weil mir der so ein bisschen,
diskussionswürdig vorkam. Also zunächst einmal erster Punkt ist hier,
ja gemeinsam runter äh auf null, also man will halt diesen Ping Pong Effekt äh vermeiden, haben wir jetzt gerade drüber gesprochen
Kontakte natürlich auf Minimo reduziert und zwar auch am Arbeitsplatz, also hier wird explizit eben auch 'ne Stilllegung der Wirtschaft gefordert, das ist,
nachvollziehbar.
Dann eben Punkt zwei, niemand darf zurückgelassen werden, also was eben auch schon dieser Endkorona bei aufgezählt hat, ne, ist klar, man muss halt einfach Leute, die in beengten Wohnverhältnissen, gewalttätigen Umfeld, Obdachlose, et cetera
sind muss was gemacht werden, Sammelunterkünfte müssen aufgelöst werden, finde ich eigentlich auch so ein Punkt, der viel zu wenig diskutiert. Ich meine, wir haben überall leere Hotels.
Ja, aber äh komme nicht mal auf die Idee, äh diese Hotels zu benutzen, um Leute dort unterzubringen, die unter Umständen vielleicht auch gar keine,
andere Möglichkeit haben. Ich habe immer mal wieder von so kleineren Maßnahmen gehört, die eigentlich ganz sinnvoll sind, dass man halt einfach auch jetzt mal Obdachlose meines weißes nicht bei allen irgendwie so ohne Weiteres möglich, aber,
auf jeden Fall die deutliche Mehrheit würde das wahrscheinlich auch annehmen,
einfach mal sagt so okay, jetzt hier die nächsten drei Monate packen wir euch in die Hotels, die Hotels sind sowieso alle unterbelegt. Man macht da einen speziellen Deal und es gibt natürlich euch äh einerseits die Chance, euch auch irgendwie fernzuhalten,
ne? Also euch auch äh entsprechend äh,
die Kontaktarmut auch durchzuleben und andererseits ist es natürlich für die Leute auch eine Chance, weil es einfach mal das Hauptproblem, dass so äh wenn du
obdachlos bist, eigentlich den ganzen Tag nur damit beschäftigt bist, der Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie du den Tag äh überlebst und wenn du halt einfach mal so die
Ruhe und geschlossenheit und sanitären Bedingungen eines Hotels äh hast, dann kannst du natürlich auch dran arbeiten, irgendwie dich selber wieder aufzubauen. Das man noch so als Nebenaspekt.
Plus, je nachdem, manche Asylbewerber heim, also nicht alle, es gibt halt auch viele, äh, wo man sagen kann, okay, die sind nass jetzt, die sind okay, aber es gibt dann sicherlich auch welche, wo man dann,
sagen müsste, okay, da sollte man die Leute vielleicht dann doch lieber in Hotels unterbringen und,
natürlich auch als wir äh hier die ja Arbeiter in der Landwirtschaft,
die da dann immer im Frühjahr und Sommer und Herbst in größeren Zahlen ins Land kommen plus,
Schlachtbetriebsmitarbeiter, die dann teilweise auch
ja in mit vier, sechs, acht Betten äh in einem Zimmer und so untergebracht waren. Es.
Geht eigentlich gar nicht. Ich hoffe, dass das inzwischen auch weitgehend abgestellt ist, dass man, wenn man gerade bei solchen äh.
Leuten äh will man nicht auch noch, dass sie, dass sie zu acht in einem Zimmer schlafen.
Die ganzen Jugendherbergen sind wahrscheinlich auch leer im Moment.
Ja, also es steht einfach genug leer, als dass man's nicht auch irgendwie anders kreativ nutzen könnte. Dritte Forderung, hier Ausbau der sozialen Gesundheitsinfrastruktur.
Klar, das kann man, glaube ich, äh einfach so unterschreiben.
Ne, also natürlich sowohl Gesundheitsämter, Behörden, die jetzt in irgendeiner Form engagiert sind in dieser ganzen Panimi brauchen natürlich mehr Personal. So.
Lohnerhöhungen werden hier angefordert. Ja gut, ich meine das ist.
Permanentes Dauerthema und äh auch die Privatisierung im Gesundheitsbereich denke ich nicht, dass die so wirklich so hilfreich äh äh sind, wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, was sie für Probleme haben.
Das Geld reinzubekommen, ja,
weil es einfach alles über diese Fallpauschale läuft und die Krankenhäuser dadurch jetzt Minus machen, dass sie eben Betten freihalten müssen und sozusagen ihre.
Ihr Verdienst, den sie normalerweise durch die äh anderen Tätigkeiten hätten, einfach wegfällt, weil sie Platz reservieren müssen. Plus die Überlastung des Personals, die Liste ist lang und ich kann Gesundheitsespekt Experte, aber.
Ja, ich hatte da ein paar Einblicke, weil ich ja äh sagen im im Beteiligungsausschuss war und äh
wir halt da äh unter anderem eben ja dem Land Berlin halt wie Wand ist und die Charité gehören deswegen äh und,
das ist Hardcore-Krankenhausfinanzierung ist äh Hardcore bei Mehrheit.
Ein duales System haben das Krankenhaus selbst und die Ausrüstung eigentlich überwiegend sollte, sagen vom wird vom Land gestellt.
Und ähm also von der öffentlichen Hand und der Betrieb aber finanziert sich,
aus der Behandlung der Patienten über Fallpauschalen.
Und da wird natürlich schon mal ohne Ende äh äh gemauschelt äh so, weil da sind irgendwie zwei verschiedene Töpfe, aus denen finanziert wird und weil die,
öffentlichen Kassen halt Klamm waren, wurden dann halt Mittel, die eigentlich äh für die Versorgung der Patienten bestimmt waren, dann,
ja für die Ausstattung und teilweise auch fürs Renovieren und so benutzt, was halt nicht sein sollte und dann dieses ganze Fallpauschalensystem,
setzt natürlich auch hier und da Fehlanreize so.
Für die Privaten, die dann bestimmte Dinge halt gar nicht tun, weil die sich dann mit den Fallpauschalensystem nicht lohnen und so und jetzt und dann gibt's aber dann zusätzlich noch einen Punkte und ein Ausgleichssystem und so. Also es ist.
Extrem komplex das ganze Thema Krankenhausfinanzierung und weil dann gibt's ja die sogenannten Betten.
Bettenpauschalen und und so, je nachdem wie viel dann vorgehalten wird, die auch äh ja, wonach sich das halt richtet, aber,
ja kompliziert. Ähm
was mir aber auch noch einfällt bei Ausbau der Gesundheitsinfrastruktur. Ich mein es wäre vielleicht auch mal was, wenn die Gesundheitsämter vielleicht auch in der Lage wären äh Tälerarbeit äh zu machen und äh nicht,
wie wir es auf Bildern gesehen haben, dann
haufenweise auch noch mit Soldaten und so und zu zehn Leuten in einem Büro sitzen, direkt nebeneinander und dann ist vierzig das halbe Gesundheitsamt Corona infiziert
und fällt aus, ja? Das wäre doch auch mal was, oder?
Sicherlich, ich weiß allerdings nicht, was da die Praxis ist derzeit. Also gewisser Hinsicht glaube ich der Problematik auch bewusst, würde ich mal unterstellen. Äh von daher keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber ich bin immer sehr stark davon ausgehen, dass halt die Möglichkeiten zu Telearbeit generell äh in dem Bereich doch sehr beschränkt.
Geräte sind jetzt Ende des Jahres dann ausgelaufen offiziell. Ja, also,
das LKI hatte jetzt sozusagen gesagt, okay, ab Anfang des Jahres machen wir das dann doch mal alles ohne Fakts. Das wundert mich so ein bisschen, das kommt von meinen Geschmack na ja je nachdem wie man sieht, neun Monate oder zwanzig Jahre zu spät.
Gut, aber auch da habe ich nicht wirklich
weiterer Punkt ist, äh dass es tatsächlich Punkt fünf auf vier komme ich gleich nochmal. Solidarische Finanzierung
Klar, kostet alles äh Geld, die Gesellschaften in Europa haben enormen Reichtum angehäuft, den sich allerdings einige wenige vermögende angeeignet haben. Gut, hier haben wir die klassische Umverteilungsdiskussion, die es an der Stelle sicherlich ganz
richtig, ich denke auch, dass diese Sondermaßnahmen im Wesentlichen bei denen genommen werden sollten, die halt äh über viel verfügen und schon sagen wir mal von einem laufenden System
überproportional
profitiert haben allein mich verlässt der Glaube daran, dass wir so ein so eine Umverteilung wirklich sehen werden, andererseits kann es ja auch nicht sein, dass das einfach weiterhin von der
der Gesellschaft getragen wird, die einfach.
Teilweise einfach auch prekär lebt und wenn ich dann so Diskussionen höre wie na ja, also FFP zwei Masken kann man jetzt aber irgendwie für Hartz vier nicht finanzieren.
Dann ist er einfach was Grundsätzliches falsch in Deutschland.
Absolut.
Ja, obwohl ich ein bisschen,
ins Grübeln gekommen bin, dass hier dieser vierte Punkt dieses Aufrufs, wo es heißt, Impfstoffe sind ein globales Gemeingut, ich zitiere mal hier eine globale Pandemie, lässt sich nur global besiegen, öffentliche und private Unternehmen müssen umgehend die erforderliche Produktion von Impfstoffen vorbereiten und durchführen. Impfstoffe sollten der privaten Profiterzielung entzogen werden
Sie sind ein Ergebnis der kreativen Zusammenarbeit vieler Menschen, sie müssen der gesamten Menschheit gehören. Also.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst, aber ich habe mich so ein bisschen geärgert über diesen Satz, weil erstens für so eine Zerokovic Strategie.
Die ja hier im Mittelpunkt steht. Mit wir sollen jetzt handeln. Wir müssen jetzt irgendwie konkrete Maßnahmen ergreifen, um die Fallzahlen runterzubekommen. Das ist das, was Sirokovic sagt.
Ist dieser Punkt meiner Auffassung nach vollkommen irrelevant?
Nicht völlig würde ich sagen. Er ist insofern relevant, dass äh wir natürlich auch darauf achten müssen, dass auch Länder, die entweder Finanzierungs oder sonstige Probleme haben,
auch genug Impfstoff kriegen, weil sonst natürlich das ganz schnell zu uns zurückschwabt. So insofern
gehört halt zu so einer
Strategie auch, also sage mal zu einer Kowit-Bekämpfungsstrategie, dass man äh tatsächlich die Welt im Blick hat und äh nicht nur äh unbedingt jetzt sich äh so, das ist richtig.
Keine Frage, aber das steht hier nicht. Ja, also das das ist nicht das, was hier steht, wenn er gestanden hätte, äh im Schopf ist es ein globales Gemeingut, wir müssen auch dafür sorgen, dass die Impfstoffe in andere Länder kommen, denn,
hätte ich da ja überhaupt gar kein Problem mit, aber das ist nicht das, was hier gesagt wird, was hier gesagt wird, ist äh die private Profiterzielung wäre an dieser Stelle ein Problem.
Wo ich sagen muss, hm, wenn man sich äh die Entwicklung von Impfstoffen anschaut, dann ist äh das Problem, dass es zu wenig davon gibt und dass die ihre Entwicklung lange dauert im Wesentlichen, die das eben.
Hier überhaupt gar keine nennenswerte Finanzierung jemals vorlag und sich deswegen in alle Ewigkeit in Zukunft zielt. Also die Nichtverfügbarkeit von Impfstoffen ist vor allem dadurch getrieben, dass es sich eben einfach für Unternehmen gar nicht lohnt,
das zu tun. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen
Okay, wir stecken generell mehr Geld in Impfstoffentwicklung und treiben jetzt alle Impfstoffe äh auf diese Art und Weise voran, wie wir es jetzt gehabt haben
Klar, ne? Kann man natürlich sagen, aber auch das ist hier nicht die Auflösung, die Auflösung ist.
Man soll sozusagen in dem Moment, wo die Unternehmen dann mit viel Arbeit äh tatsächlich zu einem Ziel gekommen sind. Äh.
Ihnen quasi dann ihre wirtschaftliche Grundlage entziehen und sagen so, ja okay, es äh schön, dass ihr für uns hier äh einen Hochdruck irgendwie eine Lösung gefunden habt jetzt äh,
Sollte aber nicht Geld damit verdienen, weil.
Ja. Also ja also ähm ich sehe da noch zwei.
Aspekte.
Da ich für falsch halte, also oder wo das nicht so viel Sinn macht, okay. Wenn man jetzt sagen gut, Impfstoffe sollen der privaten Profiterzielung.
Entzogen werden, könnte man jetzt sich auf den Standpunkt stellen und sagen, ja das ist irgendwie eine öffentliche Infrastruktur,
Aufgabe und deswegen soll das halt äh in staatlicher äh Hoheit passieren, so wie äh ja, weil nicht Verkehrsbetriebe oder.
Andere Dinge. So, nun würde das praktisch bedeuten, okay, Impfstoffe werden dann nur noch vom RKI entwickelt. Beispielsweise, ja.
Sind unser genau. Das dachte ich mir dann auch so, nachdem ich sagen so die Performance in vielen Bereichen jetzt gesehen habe, die sind zwar hier und da
sicherlich wissenschaftlich exzellent,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir besser wären, wenn wir sagen würden, okay, der ist RKI so jetzt auch noch äh sagen alleine die Impfstoffentwicklung machen. Also ich finde da schon,
dass da in dem Fall jetzt die privaten Unternehmen eigentlich ganz gut performt haben, muss man sagen. So. Das könnte man dann sagen,
aber auch noch okay. Jetzt aber im Krieg, was man sich im Zweiten Weltkrieg zum Beispiel in den USA,
hat man dann sagen,
hat man dann so im Rahmen der Kriegswirtschaft so Profit Plus Verträge gemacht. Unicost Plus hieß das Costplatz. Das heißt,
da wurden dann der Staat ein bisschen das Kostenrisiko abgenommen und hat gesagt OK wir
macht aber eine Kalkulation und wir zahlen euch quasi was es kostet plus einen festen
Gewinnaufschlag obendrauf, aber ja, ihr müsst dann hinterher sozusagen auch die Kosten offenlegen und danach richtet sich dann so ein bisschen die
Bezahlung das Ganze nur bei Impfstoffen.
Wenn wir uns mal angucken, hatten ja vor ein paar Sendungen die Kosten äh der Impfstoffe, was die Impfstoffentwicklung so gekostet hat und.
Die lagen pro Impfstoff äh jetzt zwischen ein paar hundert Millionen und zwei Milliarden ungefähr.
So und wenn wir dann äh jetzt noch so bei den bei den.
Was kostet jetzt ist jetzt die gesamte Bevölkerung durchzuimpfen selbst wenn wir da jetzt mal den,
teuersten Biontech Impfstoff nehmen, das war jetzt ungefähr sowas fünfundzwanzig Euro ungefähr fünfzehn zwischen fünfzehn und fünfunddreißig schwanken da glaube ich die Preise je nachdem ja.
Wir zahlen, glaube ich, äh in also die EU zahlt, warte mal, ich habe die Zahl hier irgendwo ähm die EU zahlt Byontech, Pfizer für zwei Dosen quasi zwanzig Euro, also ungefähr zehn Euro.
Pro Dosus.
Also zwanzig Euro pro Person, wie man jetzt sagt, achtzig Millionen durchimpfen äh kostet hundertsechzig Millionen Euro.
Ja so ähm damit ist, hm.
Es ist ein Witz, äh aber wenn man das jetzt gegenüber stellt, ich glaube die äh der Impfstoff lag so ungefähr bei knapp einer Milliarde, glaube ich, die Entwicklungskosten, wenn ich das so so richtig in Erinnerung habe, ja.
Klar. Global sieht es jetzt dann anders aus, äh wenn man jetzt, ich sage mal, eine Milliarde äh Leute impft, dann äh hätte man irgendwo zwanzig Milliarden äh ungefähr,
mit dem Impfstoff gemacht und dann refinanziert sich das Ganze sagen auch.
Wobei da jetzt noch Produktion dazu kommt und so weiter, neue Fabriken aufbauen, das kommt ja sozusagen jetzt auch nicht kostenlos.
Plus, das natürlich jetzt im Moment massiv über Kapazitäten geschaffen äh werden. Das heißt, wenn die dann damit durch sind, äh so klar werden jetzt nicht alles dicht machen müssen, aber.
Mein Punkt ist einfach nur selbst wenn du Entwicklungskosten und dann die Kosten pro Dosis äh und so zusammennimmst das sind.
Jetzt keine gewaltigen Beträge, wir reden hier jetzt nicht von Kriegswirtschaft, fünfzig Prozent des Bruttoinlandsprodukts äh oder so, sondern äh wir reden hier von äh und,
die Preise werden wahrscheinlich auch fallen und es gibt ja auch manche Impfstoffe, die sind glaube ich bei fünfzig Cent pro Dosis äh oder so, ja.
Aber ja wir reden hier jetzt nicht wirklich von gewaltigen Beträgen. So, sondern.
Auch ich meine, das war das das Irrsinnige auch so, dass die EU dann.
Zwei Komma acht Milliarden, glaube ich, ein Budget.
Für die Impfstoffbeschaffung festgelegt hat und im gleichen Atemzug äh siebenhundertfünfzig Milliarden an Wirtschaftshilfen beschlossen hat.
Was die Frage hätte man denn vielleicht nicht,
bisschen da drauf gelegt bei den Impfstoffen und dafür gesorgt, dass wir sowie in Israel äh dann halt bis März unsere Bevölkerung durchgeimpft haben und äh ja,
Das da war man, glaube ich, ein bisschen knauserig an der Stelle.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, das setzt ja immer voraus, als hätte es jetzt hier nur einen einzigen Kandidaten gegeben, von dem man von vornherein hätte klar sagen können, der ist dann auch äh wirksam und der ist dann auch in den ausreichenden Mengen verfügb,
Also es mag ja das ein oder andere für
Biontech und moderner Projekt gesprochen haben. Nur sicher sein konnte man sich natürlich auch erst nachdem diese Phase drei drei durch waren.
Von daher ist es klar, man hat da ja auch verschiedene Hersteller gesetzt und man hat da äh ganz allgemein äh verhandelt, aber,
mal auf diese Serokovic Forderung jetzt zurückzukommen. Ich sehe da einfach die Basis nicht dafür,
was ich das ist einfach eine eine sinnlose äh Forderung, die weder dem eigentlichen Ziel jetzt irgendwas beiträgt noch das jetzt an sich irgendwie eine sinnvolle Forderung ist,
ganz im Gegenteil.
Jedenfalls nicht im Zusammenhang jetzt mit Powit. Man kann natürlich darüber debattieren, dass jetzt für andere Krankheiten.
Die vielleicht nicht so sehr im Westen vorkommen, sondern dass er sich vielleicht in Afrika oder so, dass äh man da vielleicht
der Impfstoff äh Entwicklung oder der Stelle halt mehr helfen äh sollte, was ja auch,
teilweise passiert, aber sagen das jetzt direkt mit Kobit zu verbinden oder mit Zero Kovit,
ist ein bisschen äh äh schwierig, aber das Ziel zu sagen, wir müssen wir auch immer sicherstellen, dass alle Länder so schnell wie möglich genug Impfstoffe kriegen,
das halte ich für richtig, aber dafür jetzt dann.
Sagen, die Impfstoffherstellung und Entwicklung zu äh verstaatlichen, finde ich,
bisschen zu wei.
Ich find's auch kontraproduktiv. Also ich finde an der Stelle ist einfach, dass dass das Modell, dass das dort natürlich auch Profite erzeugt werden, das führt natürlich auch zu entsprechenden Investitionen, nur die Investitionen alleine schon reichen ja nicht, weil es einfach so ein High Risk,
Sektor ist so.
Gut, man kann natürlich jetzt äh argumentieren, okay.
Das ist halt so ein High Risk Sektor sowie Raumfahrt, da muss halt wie der Staat einfach rein und es ist halt schon auch so, dass ähm ja, manche Dinge,
sagen so riskant sind, dass äh sie selbst für Aventure Capital riskant sind und mein bei,
Biontech äh war ja allerdings auch so eine Geschichte. Äh die werden ja auch fast äh den Bach runtergegangen, wenn da nicht sich,
irgendwie ein Investor nochmal persönlich engagiert äh hätte, lieber ja auch wohl in Not.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Langer Zeit äh ähm.
Na gut, ich will da jetzt nicht äh länger drauf äh rumhacken und ich will auch ehrlich gesagt nicht damit sagen, ihr sollt diese Petition nicht unterschreiben, das könnt ihr natürlich trotzdem äh gerne tun, weil am Ende gibt's ja hier erstmal um was anderes. Hier geht's erstmal um dieses Sirokove Ziel und das ist jetzt generell natürlich eine gute Idee und äh auf welchen Link man da jetzt gerade äh äh klickt und sich mitzählen lässt.
Spielt äh am Ende da auch keine große Rolle mehr. Man muss jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer mit allem im Detail übereinstimmen
Ja, oben irgendwie ein Projekt äh beizuwohnen. Äh ich wollte nur diesen Aspekt jetzt auch nochmal als Seuchen diskutieren, weil ich glaube, dass ja eine eine Fehlwahrnehmung,
im Vordergrund steht, nämlich eine Fehlwahrnehmung, was eigentlich
Impfstoffe wirklich in den Markt bringt und verfügbar macht und dass wir an der Stelle eigentlich mit einem privaten Modell. Das ist das ist nicht der Teil.
Der medizinischen Gesamtwirtschaft, der irgendwie problematisch ist. Das das sieht da einfach grundsätzlich erstmal
kein Problem. Wir können das in anderen Bereichen diskutieren, wir haben's auch schon diskutiert hier mit Krankenhäusern und so weiter, also private
Modelle sind für Dinge, wo es darum geht, eine Volksgesundheit aufrecht zu erhalten, ähm teilweise eben auch kontraproduktiv, aber im Falle von Impfstoffen, die einfach wirklich High Risk äh und High End Development sind, ist es wahrscheinlich gerade eher andersrum.
Damit kommen wir auch überhaupt zum ganzen Impfthema nochmal äh genauer, wie geht's denn voran mit den Impfungen
in Deutschland und international. Da haben wir im Wesentlichen dasselbe Bild, wie wir das eigentlich auch schon vor einer Woche hatten. Wir haben einzelne Länder
allen voran natürlich Israel, äh, Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, Barain und auch die relativ gut vorankommen, wobei eben
United Kingdom auch ja früh gestartet ist, äh, sich sehr früh auf 'ne Zulassung eingelassen hat,
kann man jetzt so sehen oder so sehen ähm und äh trotzdem gibt's aber auch dort schwierige äh Debatten, wie denn jetzt sozusagen davor gegangen werden soll. Da sage ich gleich nochmal was dazu. Auch in.
Den USA kommt man ganz gut voran. Ähm! Auch wenn es besser laufen könnte, Deutschland ist na ja.
Besser als Frankreich, aber.
Besser als Frankreich und Mexiko ähm.
Schlechter als Italien.
Ja, schlechter als Italien, aber das sind auch alles äh geringe Unterschiede. Also man kann halt sagen
es lief sehr langsam an. Es hat jetzt tatsächlich in den letzten zwei Tagen etwas angezogen. Also wir dümpelten so bei vierzig, fuffzigtausend Impfungen pro Tag
äh heroben. Ich glaube, die Zahl von gestern lag dann bei vierundneunzigtausendsechshundertvierundfünfzig,
ähm muss man abwarten äh inwiefern diese Zahl jetzt noch weiter steigen kann. Es gibt ja auch hier immer so ein Sonntagsloch.
Also gemittelt ähm.
Weiß ich nicht ganz genau, liegen wir jetzt vielleicht so bei fünfzig, sechzigtausend, aber das kann eben auch sein, dass wir jetzt hier zur Beschleunigung kommen. Die sind auch erforderlich, denn so in dem Sp,
ähm werden wir hier dem ganzen Geschehen nicht nennenswert etwas entgegensetzen und es wird auch noch lange dauern bis die Todeszahlen sinken. Ich bin allerdings durchaus
zuversichtlich, dass hier noch Boden gut zu machen ist. Die Frage warum es denn nicht schneller geht? Na ja,
Die ist in aller Munde und ich habe versucht, mir so ein bisschen einen Reim drauf zu machen. Aber.
Bin ein wenig daran gescheitert, weil egal was man liest, ich habe so das Gefühl, jeder Artikel und jeder Augenzeugenbericht,
berichtet von was anderem. Teilweise heißt es, es ist nicht genug Impfstoff da, dann heißt es, es sind nicht genug,
Termine gemacht worden, die Leute kommen dann einfach nicht und äh am Abend wird dann immer bei der Feuerwehr angerufen und äh wer sich denn noch impfen lassen möchte, damit eben die angebrochenen Dosen dann verteilt werden.
Ähm.
Dass der Impfstoff kleckermäßig reinkommt, ist in dem Sinne jetzt auch nichts Neues. Äh es mag logistische Probleme geben, es gab
ein Problem hier mit diesem moderner Impfstoff, der ja jetzt auch zugelassen ist, der dann äh nicht richtig gelagert wurde, wo dann eben äh eine ganze.
Ganze Logo von Impfstoff auch wieder vernichtet werden musste.
Ja, war das? Ich hatte nur gehört äh dass die Befürchtung bestand aber, dass der dann wohl doch okay war. Oder äh.
So dass mit diesem Fiser äh Impfstoff, da gab's diesen Fall vor ein paar Wochen das Biontech sich den selber nochmal angeschaut hat, gesagt hat, nee, haben das den untersucht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das war schon jetzt äh im Zusammenhang mit dem Moderne.
Ach so, gut, dann bin ich da vielleicht nicht ganz aktuell. Also auf jeden Fall gibt's da auch sehr viel hin und her mit Lieferungen und mit Kühlkette et cetera. Also ich habe so den Eindruck
die Impfzentren an sich sind jetzt logistisch ganz gut organisiert, die haben das Personal, die haben sich aufgebaut, die sind da, die können irgendwie loslegen, was sie halt brauchen ist ein Constanta Flow von Leuten und ein konstanter Flow von äh Impfstoff. Und beides klappt
mehr oder weniger gut. Teilweise gibt's Schwierigkeiten mit den Terminvereinbarungen. Leute machen Termin, nehmen sie dann aber nicht wahr, dann tauchen die Leute einfach nicht auf. Man geht also jetzt eher dazu über, ein gewisses Überbuchen zu machen, so ein bisschen wie das die.
Wie es die Airlines machen. Mhm.
Ne? Ähm das sind natürlich Dinge, die die sich erst in der Erfahrung äh anpassen können, ist klar, weil meine was sollen sie sonst anderes machen? Erst machen sie Termine, da muss man natürlich am Anfang erstmal davon ausgehen, oh Gott, jetzt Impfung, der heiße Scheiß, alle stürzen sich drauf und äh bringen vielleicht nach ihrer Familie mit
und,
dann läuft's halt anders und du hast so und so viel Ausfall, den musst du eben jetzt mit einpreisen, dann sind natürlich viele Terminbuchungssysteme auch neu, müssen vielleicht erstmal gefixt werden
Leute finden das nicht,
ähm äh die Prozesse sind auch irgendwie unklar, sind natürlich auch wieder in jedem Land anders. Also ich glaube hier müssen wir dem Ganzen nochmal so zwei Wochen geben, bis,
bis sich das so ein bisschen eingenordelt hat, aber ich würde dann doch hoffen, dass so äh Anfang Februar mal abzusehen ist, okay, was ist denn jetzt der Takt, in dem wir hier impfen können, kriegen wir irgendwie unsere Zentren auch ordentlich ausgelagert,
ist natürlich auch ein bisschen sinnlos ist, dass wir jetzt Ärzte und es dürften ja nur Ärzte impfen. Dass Ärzte quasi dann wiederum aus ihren anderen.
Engagements abziehst, ja? Die sind ja dann nicht in ihrer Praxis nicht im Krankenhaus, sondern die sitzen dann den ganzen Tag im Impfzentrum rum, aber wenn halt so ein.
Eine Arzt, eine Ärztin da irgendwie rumsitzt und dann ganze Tag nichts zu tun hat
dann ist irgendwie auch keinem geholfen damit. Also es ist äh wieder ein anderes Problem. Muss man auch sehen, dass der Personalbedarf hier,
äh extrem ist, ne? Obwohl sie grundsätzlich glaube ich genug Personal haben, sondern das mitbekommen, dass sie in Berlin zumindest vor allem in der Veranstaltungsbranche gesucht haben nach Personal.
Also es ist so äh sehr viele Türsteher, die noch vor ein paar Monaten bei Technoclubs standen, die stehen jetzt irgendwie am Eingang des Impfzentrums.
Und auch das sonstige äh Personal rekrutiert sich teilweise zum hohen Maße aus der Veranstaltungsbranche. Was.
Einerseits ganz passend ist, weil die haben halt auch alle nichts zu tun. Also da war ohnehin ein großer,
Bedarf und Verdienstbedarf. Andererseits finde ich, bringen die auch die richtige Qualifikation mit. Weil die haben's erstmal so mit Massenaufläufen, haben die äh Erfahrung. Das sind auch äh
nicht selten so grundoptimistische äh fröhliche Menschen, das kann man da sicherlich auch ganz gut gebrauchen und ähm ja, da ist es äh eine echte Win-Win-Situation. Also ich kenne einige Leute, die da,
auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise engagiert worden sind.
Ja.
Ja, wie steht denn Berlin? Äh wie stehen denn die Bundesländer so im Vergleich eigentlich da gucke ich gerade noch.
Pommes ganz gut dabei irgendwie mit zweiundzwanzig pro Tausend.
Richtig, die liegen vorne.
Und.
So ansonsten bewegt sich alles, aber im Bereich so von Jahres ist acht bis vierzehn Schleswig-Holstein ist auch noch.
Sogar ja mit achtzehn Komma zwei und so aber ja man kann sagen.
So gewaltig sind die Unterschiede nicht. Das meiste bewegt sich. So im Bereich zehn bis fünfzehn.
Gerade, aber ansonsten ja hunderttausend am Tag sag ich mal, werden jetzt sagen wir Geschwindigkeit von hochgerechnet drei Millionen.
Im Monat, das ist natürlich noch zu wenig, aber ich finde für Mitte Januar jetzt auch nicht nicht das Allerschlechteste.
Wenn man das jetzt noch verzehnfachen so, dann äh.
Das wird eben von all diesen Faktoren abhängen und die Leute, die das organisieren, die mangeln sicherlich nicht an Motivation.
Ja, wenn ich mir das angucke, also in Berlin ging man aus von der Kapazität von, ich sage mal, ja, zwanzigtausend pro Tag, die man als Ziel haben wollte und.
Ja in Berlin sind's im Moment zweitausendzweihundert pro Tag, also insofern bin ich jetzt mit verzehnfachen eigentlich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und äh ja, das wären dann.
Bei äh verzehnfachen hätten wir eine Million am Tag und dann werden wir eigentlich.
So, müsste relativ fix durch sein, wenn er Nachschub kommt, so.
Wenn der Nachschub kommt. Viel geredet wird ja über die Impferfolge in Israel.
Und Israel ist jetzt gerade ich guck mal gerade wie es aktuell so steht. Israel.
Hat jetzt die fünfundzwanzig Prozent erreicht.
Das heißt, ein Viertel der Bevölkerung ist jetzt schon geimpft. Das ist.
Ordentlich und man fragt sich, okay, wie haben die denn das jetzt eigentlich gemacht, dass sie so viel Impfstoff äh hinkriegen, abgesehen davon, dass sie die Logistik äh natürlich auch hinkriegen müssen. Logistik hatten wir, glaube ich, schon mal drüber gesp,
das wundert uns jetzt irgendwie nicht. Ich glaube, das ist etwas, was dieses Land drauf hat. Allerdings haben sie halt mehr bezahlt,
für den Impfstoff von Bayern Tech Pfeiser, also sie sind da auf einen speziellen Deal eingegangen. Wir hatten es vorhin erwähnt, die EU zahlt zwanzig Euro
Pfeifer zahlt, äh Entschuldigung, äh Israel zahlt äh Pfeiser siebenundvierzig US-Dollar, also ungefähr so das Doppelte von dem, was die EU zahlt.
Wohl auch noch äh nimmt wohl auch noch irgendwie an speziellen Studien äh teil, um das genauer äh anzuschauen, also liefert quasi an.
Biotech äh entsprechende Daten zurück, was das genau ist, kann ich nicht äh sagen, aber natürlich sind jetzt hier alle hinterher und wollen natürlich schauen, okay, was bringt's denn jetzt, weil diese Kampagne läuft ja jetzt auch schon seit über zwei Wochen.
Wann haben die angefangen? Also ich glaube auch so um Weihnachten rum, ne.
Zwanzigsten Dezember.
Zwanzigster Dezember, genau, also wir sind jetzt so bei drei bis vier Wochen
Und tatsächlich gibt es da auch eine Studie der israelischen Krankenkasse. Klar liegt
heißt die offenbar und sie haben jetzt von den Leuten, die zuerst geimpft wurden, zweihunderttausend untersucht und das eben mit äh zweihunderttausend verglichen, die eben nicht geimpft wurden und weil das Interessante ist ja,
Nicht nur haben sie eine extrem hohe Impfquote, sondern sie haben derzeit auch noch eine extrem hohe Infektionsrate. Also vielleicht kannst du die Zahl mal k,
äh nachschlagen, wo die jetzt gerade sind, aber Israel hatte auch nochmal einen ganz starken Ausbruch, das heißt, hier kriegen wir jetzt insofern sehr interessante Daten, als dass wir eben mit
in einer Zeit einer sehr hohen Institution auch eine sehr hohe Impftätigkeit sehen. Und natürlich jetzt spannend wird zu sehen, okay, wann wirkt es sich, wie in welchem Maße aus? Und die
Erste Frage, die sie dem jetzt erstmal nachgegangen sind, weil ist klar, jetzt beginnt gerade erst die Phase der zweiten Impfung, also der zweiten Dosis.
Ne, also wer jetzt am zwanzigsten Dezember geimpft worden ist, das ist jetzt,
Ungefähr eins zwei, ja, das ist jetzt ungefähr drei Wochen her, also durftest jetzt seit ungefähr einer halben Woche sind Leute das zweite Mal geimpft worden. Wenn sie jetzt genau diesen drei Wochen Abstand einhalten
Was wir aber jetzt untersucht haben ist, was hat denn diese erste Dosis schon bewirkt.
Und da zeigt sich, dass in den ersten dreizehn Tagen seit der Impfung es keinen Unterschied gibt.
Also man wird geimpft und man kann im Prinzip sagen in den ersten zwei Wochen nüscht.
Das ist auch das, was aus den Zahlen, sowohl bei moderner als auch bei.
Genau bei von moderner, weil die hatten das auch explizit in ihrer Phase drei mituntersucht. Hatten wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, so nach zwei Wochen ging's dann los.
Genau das findet sich jetzt auch hier, denn schon ab dem.
Dreizehnten und vierzehnten Tag, also ab dann geht auf einmal die Infektionsrate deutlich nach unten und so wie man das jetzt bisher äh bewerten kann,
wie gesagt zweihunderttausend Leute man hat da jetzt vielleicht eine irgendwie eine Woche läuft das jetzt sozusagen schon sinkt die Infektionsrat bei den Leuten die geimpft wurden um ein Drittel.
Was schon mal eine Ansage ist.
Weil erstmal überhaupt schon mal Infektionsraten, um ein Drittel zu senken, das könnten wir gerade alle ganz gut gebrauchen und das natürlich davon auszugehen, dass erstens,
dann auch noch Tag zu Tag zunimmt, also wir könnten in den nächsten Wochen weitere Ergebnisse glaube ich erwarten, wie sieht's denn nach drei Wochen aus? Wie sieht's denn nach vier Wochen aus und vor allem natürlich dann, wie sieht's eben aus nach der zweiten
Impfung generell war die Ansage ja von Pfeiser als auch von,
moderner, dass man nach sechs Wochen nach der ersten Impfung.
Fünf bis sechs Wochen davon ausgehen kann, dass sozusagen wirklich die Immunität auch erreicht wird, die man,
haben will, so, ne? Und äh was man dazu sagen muss
Das ist jetzt hier eine Untersuchung der Infektionsrate, was jetzt hier noch nicht rausgefallen ist oder was ich zumindest jetzt aus diesem Bericht noch nicht habe, rauslesen können, ist Erkrankung.
Denn das war ja die Ansage, dass eigentlich alle Leute, die geimpft wurden, keine schweren Verläufe mehr hatten, also selbst die, die jetzt so unglücklich waren, sich trotzdem nach
Nachdem sie geimpft wurden, nochmal infiziert zu haben, können unter Umständen davon ausgehen zumindest keine Schwerfälle zu entwickeln, aber das wird sich noch zeigen.
Allerdings scheint Israel schon sagtest äh jetzt das mit den Infektionen einfach laufen zu lassen äh gerade.
Also äh die haben äh gerade eine Inzidenz von ungefähr sechshundertachtzig äh Neuinfektionen pro.
Hunderttausend pro Woche, also.
Dass über dreifache von dem vierfache, was wir im Moment haben und kein Ende in Sicht. Also da gab's irgendwie auch kein Weihnachtsknick oder sowas ähm.
Sondern da gehen die Zahlen straight nach oben jetzt seit seit Anfang Dezember ungebremst.
Na gut, also ich meine, wenn jetzt fünfundzwanzig Prozent geimpft sind.
Und in zwei Wochen, also Ende Januar sollte.
Sollten alle diese Leute quasi mindestens ein Drittel weniger sehen und die, die halt schon früher geimpft wurden, dann zunehmende Maße mehr,
Währenddem diese Impfkampagne weiter in hoher Geschwindigkeit weiterläuft, müsste es irgendwann einen Effekt geben.
Ja, aber man sieht halt offenbar, okay, das mit, ich sage mal, fünfundzwanzig Prozent, die jetzt geimpft wurden, heißt's jetzt auch noch nicht fünfundzwanzig Prozent Immun.
Im Moment ja an den Asieinfektionszahlen zeigen sich bisher völlig unbeeindruck.
Ja. Was hat denn Israel für Gesamtzahlen äh überhaupt? Das schaue ich nochmal kurz.
Auch.
Na ja, aber ich frage mich gerade, was denn sozusagen die, die natürliche Immunität sein müsste.
Also wenn man jetzt mal hier konfirmtases hat äh insgesamt Israel.
Hatte bisher.
Sechs Prozent.
Sechs Prozent an bestätigten Fällen. Das heißt, die kommen nochmal dazu.
Plus Dunkelziffer ja also.
Schwer zu sagen, wieder die Dunkelziffer ist.
Aber ja wahrscheinlich auch mindestens drei äh Faktor drei. Aber wie gesagt, also im Moment äh sieht man noch keine Effekte von der Impfung. Man wird.
Oder oder irgendwelcher Herden, Immunität oder so und ja, ist auch eigentlich zu erwarten oder.
Das ist auf jeden Fall jetzt im Rahmen des Erwarteten, aber es gibt eben auch gute Nachrichten, um das mal nochmal zu betonen. Also dieses
die Impfung wirkt und sie wirkt schon nach der ersten Dosis nach zwei Wochen und zeigt schon bei einem Drittel deutliche Zeichen, dass es eine sehr gute Zahl.
Aber auch vielleicht wichtige Lehre.
Weil es bestimmt Leute gibt, die denn der Meinung sind also ah jetzt habe ich irgendwie meine Impfung gekriegt, jetzt kann mir nichts mehr passieren.
Ja das ist nicht so.
Sondern in den ersten vierzehn Tagen ist es offenbar so, dass ja, wie du sagtest, ist man noch voll äh.
Empfänglich und äh ja auch hinterher sind's halt gibt es halt Fälle.
So äh wo Leute dann auch durchaus erkranken und das weitertragen. Das sind dann zwar nur, weil sie nicht fünf Prozent, zehn Prozent, aber in der Gegend, aber äh ja.
So hundert Prozent Sicherheit.
Gegen ich bin nicht infektiös, äh bietet das halt nicht, was natürlich auch wichtig ist so für die ganze.
Debatte jetzt welche Privilegien oder äh kann ich jetzt an meine meine geimpften Mitarbeiter,
irgendwie schnell verheizen dann gerade im Gesundheitswesen das schien wohl auch so ein Punkt gewesen zu sein,
Ich hatte ja auch gefragt irgendwie, wie kann das sein, dass ich im Gesundheitswesen, dass es da Leute gibt, die sich nicht impfen lassen äh wollen und da.
Kam dann so mehrere Gründe und einer davon war, dass halt die Leute befürchten, wenn sie geimpft sind, dass sie dann nur noch Schichten schieben müssen und dass sie dann gleich auf die,
irgendwie Kovic Station gepackt werden und irgendwie rund um die Uhr arbeiten müssen. Das war so eine Befürchtung, ja.
Das wird, es würde die hohen Zahlen als nicht erklären, weil natürlich auch nur ein äh gewisser Teil der äh Kräfte überhaupt,
für solche Jobs äh geeignet ist, sondern es ging ja diese Impfverweigerung oder zumindest diese Skepsis gegenüber der Impfung war ja dann auch über Verwaltungsangestellte und so weiter auch äh weit verbreitet. Ich habe da auch schon verschiedene,
Erklärungsmuster gesehen, ja vor allem so eine allgemeine Frustration des Personals so mit
Der Ärzteschaft
Ja, das die sich von denen jetzt irgendwie gar nichts sagen lassen, sonst behandelt ihr uns auch nicht gerade besonders toll, aber jetzt äh habt ihr hier die Lösung, euch glaube ich erstmal gar nichts. Also, das ist glaube ich so eine Melange aus Skepsi
und zweifeln aus der eigenen Erfahrung heraus, aus einem eigenen Unwissen heraus, aus einer
diffusen Diskussionen in der Öffentlichkeit meinetwegen auch Corona, Skeptiker, Verpeilung und sonstige Fake News oder dass die Leute zu wenig UKW hören
keine Ahnung, irgendwie eine Mischung aus allem und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, ein Teil davon wird wieder abtauen und die werden sich dann irgendwie noch fan,
und es bedarf jetzt auch erstmal einer Welle guter Nachrichten. So und,
die ersten sehen wir jetzt gerade. Deswegen habe ich das äh hier auch nochmal eingestellt.
Und ich hörte auch schon von mehreren Fällen,
wo als den Leuten dann klar wurde, dass sie sich auch zum Reisen impfen lassen müssen, sind dann auch schon irgendwie ein Drittel bis zwei Drittel plötzlich äh,
auch nicht mehr so skeptisch.
Da ist er, Herr Mallorca, dichtmachen für ungeimpfte und Ding ist durch.
Gut, ne, es gab tatsächlich aber auch ein Drittel der Leute, die dann gesagt haben, ja nee, also ich würde dann lieber auf eine Reise verzichten, aber zwei Drittel äh so äh von den Skeptikern, sage ich mal, würden dann,
doch tendenziell umschwenken.
Skeptiker wollen alle am Strand. Das ist äh das ist das Powerschwert, was wir äh da gerade führen.
Ja, Ende Januar kommt unter Umständen noch ein dritter Impfstoff äh mit dazu. Dann ist nämlich so der Termin bei der EMA, wenn sie sich das äh Astra Sinneka, also von der.
Universität Ochsford entwickelten Impfstoff anschauen und dann gegebenenfalls
zulassen werden. Da gab's ja eine ganze Menge Heckmick, um diese Phase drei haben wir ja auch schon drüber berichtet, dass es irgendwie diese doppelte,
gab, so in USA halt mit irgendwie normaler Dosis zweimal, dann in UK, mit erst halber Dosis, dann volle Dosis und dann gab's dann auf einmal viel bessere Ergebnisse, ähm,
ja
Ja, das ist ja, das ist ja so ein klassischer Vektorimpfstoff äh weil fällt noch ein eine.
Sagen ein Einwurf äh äh kam halt auch noch, weswegen Leute jetzt sagen, na ja, das mit dem RNA-Impfstoff alles schön und gut, aber es gibt,
wohl da auch Studien des äh diese Lipidhüllen äh äh.
Wohl ähm ja durchaus
auch bei manchen Leuten in hoher Dosis oder so äh zu äh äh Zellveränderungen äh führen können, dass das nicht ganz unproblematisch äh sein soll.
Veränderung.
Dass äh sozusagen das, dass diese Lipide äh halt äh einfach nicht gut sind. So, dass sie halt Zellschädigen äh äh sind.
Schädigend.
Yeah. Äh also ich habe da durchaus auch also
da gibt's entsprechende äh Tierversuche und äh so wo das festgestellt wurde allerdings ist mir unklar in welcher Konzentration und so. Also
Punkt ist, du kannst mit den Lipiden sehr wohl in hoher Konzentration, also sie sind nicht
ganz nicht hundertprozentig sagen äh die sind jetzt in jeder Konzentration und für jeden völlig unbedenklich. So,
ja? Aber ähm erstmal muss,
sagen wenn jetzt der Astra Sinika im Stoff kommt,
ähm könnten dann auch ähm sagen, all diejenigen, die jetzt Angst haben mit einem
völlig neuen RNA-Impfstoff geimpft zu werden, können sie dann halt
etwas nehmen, was jetzt schon seit äh vielen vielen Jahren in vielen anderen Kombinationen erprobt ist, so.
Ja gut, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass der keine äh keine Fettsäuren enthält äh enthält so. Also es ist also sozusagen auch nur ein Virus.
Ja ja, ja, gut, aber es ist, es ist schon, wenn jemand jetzt, also es ist äh.
Dann eine andere Lipidö äh äh Hülle. So, ich sage ich mal.
Und äh und wie gesagt ich kann jetzt durchaus, ich meine, ich persönlich hätte da jetzt keine Angst äh bei dem RNA im Stoff, muss ich sagen, weil äh.
Der einfach genauso gut,
erforscht ist wie alle anderen Impfstoffe die es die es gibt ja? Ähm das Ganze ging halt nur deswegen so schnell muss man auch immer wiederholen, weil es halt so viele Infizierte gab.
Weil man halt sonst normalerweise viele viele Jahre braucht, um überhaupt auf äh genug Zahlen zu kommen über die äh ja Sicherheit äh von dem,
Impfstoff und Wirksamkeit ging das dank der Pandemie halt alles recht fix. So das heißt ähm.
Das Ding hat halt alle wirklich sehr sehr streng äh Maßstäbe, die man an Impfstoffe so anlegt, erfüllt.
Dann kommt noch dazu, dass ja äh seit fünfzig Jahren äh und länger geimpft wird in großem Maßstab.
Und wenn man die damaligen Impfstoffe von vor fünfzig Jahren oder so vergleicht mit dem, was wir heute haben, dann sind die um so viel verträglicher und sicherer
so also insofern ja.
Eben im Vergleich zu dem Virus, zu einem, zu einem lebenden äh Potenten sich selbst vermehrenden Virus äh sind eigentlich äh.
Ganzen Impfstoffe sowas von äh sicher.
Ja, also ich will das wollte da jetzt eigentlich gar nicht äh weiter drauf eingehen, aber dadurch, dass du jetzt mal angesprochen hast.
Ich habe mich auch nochmal so ein bisschen schlau äh gemacht, so meinem Biochemischen Umfeld. Ist nicht besonders großes, aber da so ein paar äh Quellen einfach auch, um mal so ein bisschen.
Zu verstehen, wie denn das so ist, ne, weil man.
Hört ihr immer so viel von ja der Virus hier mit seinem Spike-Protein und der klopft damit irgendwie alles ab und trinkt damit irgendwie in die Zellen ein, ne?
Da habe ich mich so gefragt so ja ähm okay, aber wenn der das braucht, um irgendwie in Zellen einzudringen, warum braucht denn der Impfstoff das nicht.
Reicht's da einfach nur irgendwie warum reichen da einfach nur diese diese Lipidhöhlen.
Und ich war jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überrascht und wenn du sagst, du hast da Studien, dann bitte mal äh bitte Link bei die Fische, weil äh das würde ich jetzt ganz gerne mal äh sehen,
denn die Tatsache, dass das sozusagen so einfach funktioniert, dass der Virus ja eigentlich im Wesentlichen,
Anführungsstrichen nur aus so einer Lipidhülle besteht. Plus, dann ist da diese RNA da drin.
Und das war's ja eigentlich schon. Mehr mehr ist in diesen mehren A Stoffen nicht drin, ja? Da ist kein kein Virus gar nichts, da ist einfach nur so eine so eine Programmkopie zur Herstellung dieses Bike-Proteins,
enthält aber selber das nicht und warum trinkt denn das ein? So, ja weil das eben ausreicht,
unsere Zellen sind halt einfach im Wesentlichen,
durch diese Fettsäuren, durch diese lipide äh selber umgeben und dann kann dann halt einfach so ein Impfstoff dann einfach eindringen, dadurch, dass einfach Fettsäure auf Fettsäure äh trifft,
genaue Zusammensetzung dieser Hülle.
Muss natürlich auch nochmal anderen Anforderungen sprechen, nämlich im Wesentlichen der Anforderung der Produktion, auf der einen Seite, aber dann eben auch der Lagerung und der Halterung. Man möchte.
Eben, dass es eben,
einfach zu lagern ist und wir sehen, dass es ein Problem bei Bio und Tech muss diese Hülle eben mit minus siebzig Grad vorgehalten werden, um dauerhaft zu halten und dann eben innerhalb von fünf Tagen aufgebraucht werden, wenn diese Kühlung nicht mehr gegeben ist,
die sich jetzt moderner dort ausgesucht hat und entwickelt hat
scheint nicht ganz so hohe Anforderungen zu haben, kommt erstmal minus zwanzig Grad aus und so weiter und ist dann auch noch eine Weile im Kühlschrank haltbar
es ist also einfach eine andere technische Entwicklung und ich denke, diese technische Entwicklung wird auch noch weitergehen und noch weiter verbessert werden. Die Probleme, die bisher in den Phase drei Studien gesehen wurden, waren halt
Leute, die eben generell einfach ein ähm
wie soll ich sagen, leicht verspultes Immunsystem haben und dann eben allergische Reaktionen haben auf Dinge, die eigentlich dem Körper nicht schaden.
Da ist dann aber dieser Impfstoff nicht das erste, wo die Alarm schlagen, sondern es sind einfach Leute, die generell Probleme haben, die,
bei denen einfach allergisch über Reaktionen zum zum Krankheitsbild oder zum zu im normalen Gesundheitszustand einfach dazugehören und die dann eben auch,
stärker reagieren, was dann aber eben in Rahmen dieses Impfprozesses auch kein großes Problem ist, denn wenn das dann auftritt,
was natürlich passieren kann, was sicherlich auch in dem Moment nicht schön ist, weil dann eben so ein allergischer Schock ausgelöst werden kann, der potentiell gefährlich sein kann. Deswegen werden die Leute ohnehin in Krankenhäusern.
Geimpft und können dann auch entsprechend behandelt werden und das ist auch alles behandelbar und da gab's jetzt irgendwie auch noch keine Todesfälle und auch keine Langzeitfolgen
davon, dass es dann einfach ein akute medizinische Situation, der man mit gängigen Medikamenten und Behandlungsmethoden äh etwas entgegensetzen kann und wenn das in Griff äh ist, dann ist das auch vorbei
Weitere Einflüsse,
Davon habe ich jetzt nichts gehört, ne? Das können wir gerne mal weiter verfolgen äh und später nochmal aufgreifen, wenn wir da belastbares Material haben.
Ich gehe davon aus.
Aber das genau das gucken wir uns ähm mal an. Äh aber äh also ich gehe äh davon aus, dass,
in den Dosen, in denen das äh verimpft äh wird äh so und die Gruppen äh dass das so sicher ist, äh wie halt.
Ein Impfstoff nur sein kann, aber wie gesagt, ich kann das äh äh durchaus auch nachvollziehen, wenn jemand sagt, hm, ich will jetzt nicht der Erste sein, der,
sagen an dem eine völlig neue Art von von Impfstoff erprobt wird. Das halte ich erstmal für eine für eine nachvollziehbaren Gedanken,
Gang. Äh nur, dass wir jetzt gehört haben. Ähm.
Die meisten Leute in Deutschland werden mitnichten die Ersten sein, äh sondern wahrscheinlich irgendwie die fünfhundert Millionsten oder so auf der Welt.
Also es sind jetzt fünf, fünfunddreißig, fünfunddreißig Millionen Impfdosen verteilt worden von verschiedensten ähm also von verschiedensten Impfstoffen, aber vor allem sehr viel von diesem MRNA.
Ja gut, dann gibt's natürlich wieder auch Leute, die kommen dann näher, aber die Langzeit folgen, wer weiß, wie das dann in fünf oder zehn Jahren aussieht. Äh aber gut.
Wo man zu sagen kann.
Das ist generell nichts, was bei Impfstoffen jemals bisher so aufgetreten wäre. Es gibt keine langzeitfolgen von Impfungen. Langzeitfolgen sind im Sinne von Impfung, ein Zeitraum von sechs Wochen.
Was in sechs Wochen nicht aufgetreten ist, ist nicht aufgetreten. Es gibt bei keinem Impfstoff jemals auch nicht bei denen, die problematisch waren, Probleme, die,
sehr viel später irgendwie Jahre später in irgendeiner Form aufgetreten werden, die sich auf äh diese Verimpfung hätte zurückführen lassen können. Deswegen, das Ding ist überschaubar,
Wir haben jetzt seit,
vier Wochen, nehmen dann noch ein bisschen früher, sechs Wochen, also etwas mehr als ein Monat, sage ich mal, finden Impfungen statt.
Jetzt ist äh das so, wenn irgendwie ein Problem auftritt, dann das irgendwie bis Ende Januar auf,
Aber bisher ist halt noch überhaupt nichts gewesen.
Und wahrscheinlich kann man auch sagen, wird gibt es kaum einen Impfstoff, der äh jetzt dann an so vielen Menschen äh getestet in Anführungszeichen sein wird, äh wie wie dieser, ja?
Gut, lass uns äh weiter schreiten. Sendung ist schon lang.
Paar Kleinigkeiten haben wir noch. Ich habe nochmal äh ein bisschen Fernsehen geguckt und zwar hatte ich schon mal erwähnt, da äh Podcast, der ja in den USA.
Auch für Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht, das das sozusagen äh so ein bisschen.
Die Drostens Amerikas, die dabei zusammensitzen und immer so aktuelle Diskussionen haben rund um die Nachrichtenlage,
Und die sind dann auch mal auf ein paar Aspekte eingegangen, insbesondere im Hinblick auf diese Frage,
kann man sich vielleicht die Zweitdose sparen? Also diese ganze Debatte oben oh Gott, wir haben nicht genug Impfstoff, führt ja einige Länder und ich glaube so eine Diskussion gibt's gerade in UK.
Äh dazu zu sagen, so ah na ja, gucke mal hier, die erste Impfung, die hilft ja auch schon. Wenn man jetzt irgendwie die zweite Dosis später äh geben.
Dann dann kriegen wir jetzt erstmal mehr Leute erst verimpft. Das hilft uns ja irgendwie. Na ja,
Und das wurde dort ausführlich diskutiert und äh grundsätzlich kann man sagen,
an dieser Vorgehensweise gibt's 'ne Menge Kritik allen voran ist die FDA, also die zuständige Behörde in USA strikt dagegen sowas zu tun
vor allem, weil's halt auch einfach überhaupt gar keine Daten dazu gibt. Ich meine, die ganze Phase drei, die man jetzt gemacht hat, ist eben einfach mit diesen zwei Dosierungen an Start gegangen und das ist eben dann letzten Endes das Ergebnis gewesen, würde man das jetzt einfach anders machen, als es in diesen
Phase da drei Tests gelaufen ist.
Hätte man quasi ein Vorgehen für das es keine Daten gibt. Also diese ganze Nachweisbare Wirkungs äh Kraft von den MRNA-Impfstoffen von fünfundneunzig Prozent.
Dann gäb's halt erstmal keine Daten, wenn man das nicht genauso durchführt, wie das in dieser Studie gemacht worden ist.
Kleine Tests wohl irgendwie mit einer Teilnehmerzahl von tausend Leuten. Da hatte man dann,
nach zwei Wochen wohl auch 'ne Effizienz von zweiundfünfzig Prozent nach mehreren Wochen dann auch zweiundneunzig Prozent
tausend Leute ist halt kein Vergleich zu dem was die großen Studien gemacht hat
und so oder so zeigt sich in dem Moment, wo man eine zweite Dosis gibt, haben die Personen deutlich mehr Antikörper. Also es ist einfach die,
Die Wirksamkeit auf der einen Seite und dann eben auch vielleicht der die Dauer des Verbleibs des Impfstoffs im Körper. Ja, das äh.
Ist dann eben das Fragezeichen.
Meinst du äh die Immunität äh nicht des Impfstoffs, sondern äh.
Was habe ich falsch gesagt?
Der verbleibt des Impfstoffs im Körp.
Der ja der Verbleib der Wirksamkeit des des Impfstoffs, also die die
die Körper, die halt aufgebaut werden. Das ist ja ein komplexes System und äh dementsprechend ist es eben auch wichtig, diese zweite Dosis zu geben,
Das wird alles beobachtet und die gehen aber davon aus, dass man dazu wirklich Daten erst zu Ende des Jahres über äh haben wird. Dann wurde nochmal ausführlich diskutiert, was denn,
Diese zweite Dose ist eigentlich genau macht, also wie funktioniert dieser Impfstoff? Die erste Dosis.
Aktiviert im Körper eben die sogenannte Primery Reaction, diese Primärreaktion. Und das führt vor allem zu dieser Bildung, dieser TZ,
Im Immunsystem sind die Teezellen sind die Zellen, die halt infizierte Zellen angreifen können. Das heißt, die sind in der Lage,
Eine Zelle, die von einem Virus übernommen wurde und dort eben viel Virenmaterial äh erstellt, was ich genau wie diese Zellen dann nach außen sich quasi,
darstellen, dass diese Teezellen, die äh finden und vernichten können, aber das ist das, was sie tun.
Und wenn die zweite Dosis gegeben wird, dann trainiert diese zweite Dosis eben diese B Zellen. Und das sind quasi die,
Produktionsfabriken für die eigentlichen Antikörper. Sprich in diesem, diese Bildzellen sind so schlummernde Fabriken und in dem Moment, wo man,
das zweite Mal Virus in den Körper bekommt und das Virus sagt so, oh ja, ich bin's hier, saß Kopf zwei, was geht? Äh ich will mich hier mal umschauen. Dann
kommen halt die B-Zellen und sehen so, ah okay, hier wurde äh erkannt.
Haben wir schon mal gesehen und produzieren dann in sehr kurzer Zeit eben diese Antikörper neu, die dann eben direkt sich ans Virus anlagern, an dieses Bike-Proteine, die quasi verkleben und damit eben
deaktivieren. Das ist sozusagen genau das, was man haben will. Und mit in so einem Aufbau von B-Zellen.
Hat das äh Immunsystem einfach mehr,
Der Affinität zum Virus und damit eben eine effektivere äh Reaktion und auch eine Verfeinerung der äh Reaktion.
Die B-Zellen, das ist sowieso, dass es, das ist ultra cool, äh, wie das.
Abläuft also dass da Sach trainiert die B-Zellen, das halt quasi so ähm,
dass es im Körper dann verschiedene Labore gibt, Zuchtlabore für B-Zellen äh erstmal. Ähm,
wo dann verschiedene Varianten gemacht werden und dann wird geguckt, äh wie,
gut äh ist jetzt äh das, was diese Varianten produzieren, äh wie äh wie gut geht das jetzt,
Also wie gut sind deren Antikörper und,
dann werden halt sozusagen die erfolgreichsten genommen, also da wird quasi so eine Art auch ihr wollt, findet so ein kleiner, schneller, evolutionärer Prozess äh äh,
statt, ähm wo dann halt, ja, die passenden B-Zellen äh konstruiert werden, die dann im Körper verbleiben.
Genau.
Dieser Drei-Wochen-Abstand wird allgemein als ein guter äh Zeitpunkt gesehen, weil diese Primärreaktion dann eben abgeklungen ist. Also diese.
Erste Reaktion, die diese T-Zellen macht, das geht dann schnell hoch und lässt dann nach einer Weile nach und nach ungefähr drei Wochen ist dann eben diese Primärreaktion abgeklungen und deswegen ist es dann,
in diesem Bereich
Der genaue Sweetspot ist dann abhängig von dem jeweiligen Impfstoff. Das muss man rausfinden. Moderner sagt ja auch vier Wochen, glaube ich und äh Fazit drei Wochen, aber irgendwo so in diesem Bereich
ist dann eben auch einfach auch der richtige Zeitpunkt gekommen. Man kann's natürlich auch noch ein bisschen herauszögern
und es kann auch sein, dass man wenn man zwischendurch dann infiziert wird, dass es dann sozusagen auch äh dieses diesen Boost-Effekt,
hat wie eine zweite Impfung, aber umso früher man das halt macht, umso.
Effektiver funktioniert das Ganze und ist halt einfach auch für die Durchimpfung der ganzen Bevölkerung und der ganzen Immunisierung der Bevölkerung einfach sinnvoller.
Na ja, also die sehen auch in dieser Debatte kann man halt auch nochmal diese Frage mit warum läuft sie nicht so richtig gut? Also in USA obwohl sie schon so viel mehr impfen als es jetzt Deutschland zum Beispiel tut,
Ja, also im Verhältnis zur Bevölkerung äh sind die dann auch noch weit hinter dem, was sie eigentlich in den Kühlschränken haben, also der größte,
Teil der Impfstoffe, die die USA haben, liegt in Kühlschränken und ist noch überhaupt nicht in die Bevölkerung gegeben, weil's da einfach logistisch,
irgendwie Probleme gibt, kann man sich natürlich gut vorstellen mit der aktuellen Regierung und dem Gesamtzustand des Landes. Deswegen äh ja muss man gucken, ne.
Ist es ein bisschen schwierig, also da wurden teilweise schon Termine für die zweite Dosis abgesagt.
Ob das irgendwie so toll ist, weiß ich nicht, wenn man sich halt die Daten anschaut, erste Dosis, um das mal vielleicht auch zu quantifizieren, die Antikörpermenge,
Körper so die durchschnittlich die da gemessen wurde lag so bei achttausendsechshundert. Nach einer zweiten Dosis liegt sie bei dreiundsechzigtausend. Also das ist weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau.
Zahlen erhoben werden, aber das wurde hier genannt und ja dementsprechend.
Klares Votum für zweite Dosis bitte genau zeitgemäß äh im Sweetspot anbringen und bei jedem und nicht solche Debatten führen über Verfügbarkeit
am Ende vergeigen wir uns damit diese ganze Impfung und die Immunisierung der Bevölkerung.
Und am Ende ja wer weiß nicht, dass das so sein muss, aber grundsätzlich.
Ist es eher so, dass man Mutationen üblicherweise im Labor gerne äh dadurch erzeugt, dass man,
wie ähm ja äh das Ganze jetzt auf Kulturen äh.
Loslässt oder äh ja auf auf ähm ein geschwächtes Immunsystem. So, sage ich mal und ähm.
Ja, also so eine halbe Immunisierung ähm weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ob das.
Jetzt Probleme macht, aber wie du schon richtig sagst, dass keiner weiß, was passiert und der Nutzen ist nun ein Bruchteil davon, also insofern.
Fände ich das auch extrem problematisch vor allem finde ich was gar nicht geht ist wenn du dir
die erste Dosis abholst in der Erwartung, dass du auch sicher deine zweite Dosis so wie vorgeschrieben bekommst und dann kriegst du es nicht, also das finde ich.
Ist eigentlich fast schon kriminell. Das geht nicht, das kann man nicht machen. Und.
Ich sage mal äh wir wissen, dass sich wahrscheinlich innerhalb der nächsten Wochen.
Die die Zahl der Impfungen,
viel viel größer ähm werden wird, sei es das, was man jetzt vermeintlich
die Anbeschleunigung da reinbringt, ist, wie wir in Israel gesehen haben, auch Epidimeologisch äh bringt das halt alles gar nichts.
So
Und äh die also Vergleich zu einfach mal jetzt ein paar Wochen abwarten, äh dann ähm sollte man einfach dieses Risiko nicht eingehen.
Ist meine Meinung dazu.
Meiner Meinung ist genauso. So, jetzt natürlich die Frage für uns alle, wann kommen wir denn dran?
Ich habe äh jetzt kommen wir doch noch Schüsse die unterhaltsamen Teilen hier. Äh ach nee, ich habe noch eine nicht ganz so unterhaltsame äh Sache, aber es gibt einen Impfterminrechner.
Keine Ahnung, auf wie guten Daten das so abläuft, aber kannst ja mal äh klicken oder hast du schon gemacht, weiß gar nicht, hast du's äh gesehen.
Ja, ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich habe ihn äh auch äh gerade äh da, ja.
So, das geht sozusagen auf der Basis von, wie laufen die Impfungen gerade und in welcher Kategorie wird man eigentlich reingestellt äh nach den veröffentlichten Sachen
ich hab das mal so durchgeklickt mit meinen Daten, die im Wesentlichen so na ja ich bin so im Mittelalter und habe keine Vorerkrankung und muss auch niemanden betreuen, also nicht so gute Karten.
Und da kam dann irgendwie äh die Information, dass ich äh dass neunzehn.
Komma drei Millionen Leute vor mir in der Warteschlange sind.
Und das bei der aktuellen Impfrate, die ja langsam wieder steigt, wie wir schon gesehen haben, ähm meine erste Impfdosis ähm,
irgendwann vom fünften achten bis,
fünften achten einundzwanzig bis neunzehnten zweiten zweiundzwanzig zu erwarten wäre. Oh man ich hoffe das dass die Impfrate noch steigt.
Rechnen, okay, hier ist eine Zahl irgendwie von Zeit, alle zu Impfen, vier Komma eins fünf Jahre. So, äh ja, also hm.
Auf Basis der aktuellen Impfrad, die definitiv noch steigen wird, ne? Gibt so einige äh Videos, die versuchen solche äh Voraussagen zu machen.
Und ähm ein anderes Budget, was ich auf meinem Telefon hat, spricht von Herdenimonität, neunter achter, zwanzig fünfundzwanzig.
Super. Könnt ihr mal klicken, vielleicht bringt euch das was. Äh vielleicht macht euch das auch noch ähm.
Unruhig. Was mich ein bisschen unruhig gemacht hat, war diese Debatte um Datenschutz. Und da kann ich das fast jetzt nur aufmachen, aber nicht zu,
Gab so einen Artikel, dass irgendwie spezielle Niedersachsen, die irgendwie ja auch gerade überhaupt nicht in die Puschen kommen und das ist auch was damit zu tun haben, dass hier irgendwie die Leute überhaupt nicht äh,
benachrichtigt bekommen und dass sie halt auch interessanterweise nicht über die Einwohnermeldedaten gehen.
Weil angeblich Datenschutzgründe dagegen sprechen würden.
Haben wir es wieder, der Datenschutz, der uns irgendwie die ganze Pandimie versaut, ne? Ähm.
Ich habe da mal so ein bisschen auf Twitter rumgefragt und sehr unterschiedliche Einschätzungen bekommen. Also klassisch äh die Regel zwei äh,
Zwei Anwälte, drei Meinungen, ne und ähm einerseits wird behauptet, das sei jetzt quasi ein Fehl
des Gesundheitsministers, weil sie in diese Corona-Impfverordnung das nicht explizit reingeschrieben haben, dass man auf diese Einwohnermeldedaten zugreifen darf
ja? Andererseits gibt es aber auch die Darstellung von Leuten, unter anderem auch von ähm des ehemaligen Datenschutzbeauftragten Peter Schar.
Dass das irgendwie alles Unsinn sei. Selbstverständlich könnte man äh auf die Daten zugreifen. Ähm darauf wurde ich auch von anderen Leuten hingewiesen, dass also DSGVO äh Artikel sechs sagt, zum Beispiel.
Dass äh die Verarbeitung rechtmäßig ist, wenn
Sie erforderlich es, um lebenswichtige Interessen der betroffenen Person oder einer anderen natürlichen Person zu schützen. Die Verarbeitung ist für die Wahrnehmung einer Aufgabe erforderlich, die im öffentlichen Interesse liegt oder an Ausübung öffentlicher Gewalt erfolgt, die dem Verantwortlichen übertragen wurde
das ist denke ich mal, kann man hier an dieser Stelle durchaus gelten lassen. Auch das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, Paragraph drei spricht hier von.
Verarbeitung, Personen bezogener Daten durch öffentliche Stellen die Verarbeitung, Personenbezogener Daten durch eine öffentliche Stelle ist zulässig, wenn sie zur Erfüllung der,
der Zuständigkeit des Verantwortlich liegenden Aufgabe oder in Auszuübung öffentlicher Gewalt, die dem Verantwortlichen übertragen wurde erforderlich ist,
denke mal so Pandemieschutz gilt dazu äh gilt da äh auf jeden Fall und auch im niedersächsischen,
Datenschutzgesetz ist eigentlich.
Relativ klar, dass in dem Moment, wo es im öffentlichen Interesse liegt oder in Ausübung öffentlicher Gewalt äh die dem Verantwortlichen übertragen wurde erfolgt. Also.
Etwas reale Diskussion. Ich habe mich sehr gewundert, denn was sie in Niedersachsen machen ist. Sie greifen jetzt auf die Adressdaten der Post zu.
Super. Das ist ja.
Und plausibilisieren dann auch noch irgendwie die Daten teilweise, indem sie quasi über den Vornamen das Alter mitschätzen.
Also da bin ich ja komplett ins Essen gefallen.
Vor allem wie wie soll denn das bitte, also Niedersachsen kann ich mir das ja vielleicht doch vorstellen, aber im Prenzlauer Berg geht das ja komplett zusammen, weil äh.
Ja, ist ja wie alle Kinder irgendwie nur noch äh Fritz und Klaus Walter. Ähm da wird er richtig schön in die äh in in Biedermeier gegriffen bei der Namenswahl. Bin ja mal gespannt, wie das so ausgeht.
Ja, also äh.
Sind wir überhaupt nicht kompetent, würde ich jetzt mal sagen in diesem Bereich. Ich habe das nur so aufgegriffen.
Also ja, so spontan würde ich aber auch ähm sagen gut erstmal beide.
Methoden sind tendenziell nicht wirklich problematisch, weil ähm ja.
Gut, äh da ähm ich meine, die weiß ja nicht, was da drin steht in der Einladung, aber ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass das ja nur ausschließlich Alters basiert läuft oder? Wenn mehr mehr geht ja nicht, da steht ja nicht drin, ob jemand irgendwelche noch Erkrankungen oder so hat. Das.
Einwohnermelderegist, also und ähm ja also klar.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht irgendwo im Internet eine Liste rumfliegen haben mit Name, Adresse und Alter äh von bestimmten Personen so. Sofern,
sind es schon schützenswerte Daten, aber ähm ja.
Man wenn das Gesundheitsamt hat viel, viel sensiblere Daten, nämlich über äh eventuelle Meldepflichtige Erkrankungen äh von von mir.
So und,
wenn die, die nicht schützen können, ich meine, was soll also mein Alter ist im Vergleich dazu nicht mal so äh äh kritisch oder oder relevant äh in dem äh Zusammenhang.
Versteht das auch nicht. Also ich meine es geht hier dadrum, Leuten einen Brief zu schreiben.
Vielleicht noch einen Code zu geben. So, das heißt, alles was du machen musst, ist, aus einer,
Gemeinde Meldedatenbank. Ich meine, das ist ja irgendwie Gemeindeebene. An der Stelle ist ja kein kein Landesdatenbank oder so, sondern in der Gemeinde sind die Leute gemeldet. Alles, was du machen musst, ist äh zu sagen, äh Selektrom,
alle die hier gemeldet sind, wer Datum Geburtsdatum vor sowieso. So, dann kriegst du da eine Liste mit einer Adresse und einen Namen.
Dann hast du da deinen Datensatz, dann schickst du den zum Briefdienstleister und sagst hier drück mal Brief.
Ich meine heutzutage kannst du sowas digital direkt bei dem bei dem, der die Briefe verteilt, abliefern.
Da werden die die Briefe lokal gedruckt, reisen noch nicht mal mehr durch die die Stadt, werden dann sozusagen Datensatz zu Papier,
konvertiert und lokal in kleine Fächer geschmissen. Das ist irgendwie alles.
Gut die ich mein gut ich,
habe mich zwar jetzt auch nicht ausführlich mit den mit dem Pro und Kontra von Einladung verschicken, Versus äh jetzt sich selber melden und,
sich einen Termin holen so ähm,
Amerikaner machen glaube ich Mangels vermutlich auch von Melderegister machen's halt so, dass die Leute sich einfach dann,
registrieren können
und mein an sich hätte es nicht auch getan, einen Aufruf irgendwie bitte jetzt alle über Achtzigjährigen,
so einfach mit Perso oder wie auch immer sich anmelden oder einfach sogar gut kommen, mehr weiß ich nicht, aber sich einen Termin besorgen.
Also ich halte das nicht für eine unlösbare Aufgabe, aber das ist sozusagen schon daran scheitern soll, dass man keinen Zugriff auf Einwohnermeldedaten. Wenn wozu haben wir denn diese Daten.
Also wenn wenn man sie in der Pandemie nicht benutzen kann, um Leute eines bestimmten Alters herauszufinden, dann können wir einfach das Meldewesen einfach auch komplett sein lassen. Also dann dann sehe ich mich überhaupt nicht, sehe ich überhaupt nicht ein, warum ich mich noch melden soll. Warum denn?
Nur damit er mir eine GEZ-Rechnung schicken könnt.
Ja eigentlich was du haben willst ist ähm ich sag mal beides. Du willst die, du willst die Leute, du willst die Leute anschreiben,
Aber du willst ihnen auch die Möglichkeit geben einfach sich von sich aus irgendwie zu melden und zu,
registrieren, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, also ich habe das jetzt nicht alles vollständig durchdrohen, aber ich denke, im Wesentlichen geht's dadrum, den Leuten eine Mitteilung zu machen, dass sie sich melden können.
Wenn man nicht so ohnehin, manche Bundesländer haben ja einfach ein Portal, da kannst du dich eintragen. So,
Jetzt könnten Berlin macht's irgendwie anders und sagt, wir schreiben die Niedersachsen, beiße ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, was ihre Methode ist. So, was willst du denn eigentlich verhindern, ne? Du willst ja irgendwie Missbrauch verhindern,
Aber am Ende werden die Leute ja sowieso am Impfzentrum gecheckt, ob sie irgendwie den Kriterien entsprechen. Also verstehe ich gar nicht, warum man nicht einfach.
Termin machen kann.
Und dann sagt man ja hier, ich habe das und das Alter, das musste dann belegen und wenn es nicht belegen kannst und wenn du nicht in der Kategorie bist, ne, dann wirst du halt wieder.
Meine meine meine Rede, als.
Dafür gibt's diese äh Türsteher vom Technoclub. Die, wenn die irgendwas können, dann ist es Leute wieder wegschick.
Das können die gut.
Ja und wahrscheinlich war die Befürchtung
dass man nicht in der Lage ist, Internetseiten zu bauen äh auf die Millionen von Leuten plötzlich zugreifen wollen und sich einen Termin besorgen äh.
Ja gut, auch da kannste ankündigen und sagen heute nur dieses Geburtsdatum so.
Heute nur dieses Jahr, morgen das nächste Jahr, was weiß ich, mein Gott, das kann doch nicht so schwierig sein.
Nein, ist es beim ja.
Furchtbar. Okay, lass uns weitermachen. Ähm.
Wo wir noch gar nicht so drüber gesprochen haben und ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich jetzt hier so viel Nennswertes zu beitragen kann, aber diese ganze Debatte um diese UK-Varus-Variante, diese B hundertsiebzehn Variante geht ja immer äh
weiter. Das paart sich dann eben auch mit diesen ganzen Siroko wird aufrufen
weil natürlich jetzt diese Einschätzung äh kommt mit, wenn wir einen Virus haben, was sich noch besser verbreitet, dann sind halt unsere Maßnahmen noch weniger geeignet in irgendeiner Form zugreiften, als sie es ohnehin schon sind.
Wohl jetzt auch Erkenntnisse aus weitere Erkenntnisse aus England, die das nochmal bestätigen und weil ich das gesehen habe, wohl auch,
aus Dänemark,
das CDC entsprechend Alarm geschlagen hat. Wir haben ja schon diskutiert, den Markt schon wieder rückläufige Zahlen, also das könnte durchaus auch funktioniert haben.
Und es werden jetzt auch erste Studien äh gemacht, die halt einfach gucken, okay wie ist denn jetzt äh wie sind diese Reinfektionsraten, also inwiefern kann eben das neue Virus hier,
mit den alten Antikörpern klarkommen, ne und soweit sieht das aber bisher abzeichnet, gibt's da bestenfalls so eine Reduktion um null Komma fünf Prozent.
Meine Studie verlinkt.
Also das ist alles noch nicht in einem besonders alarmierenden Bereich. Also wer das jetzt nicht verstanden hat, die Kernaussage ist die die neuen Virenvariante mag sich zwar besser verteilen, mag sie besser,
verbreiten, ja? Durch die eine oder andere Strategie, die glaube ich byologisch noch nicht vollständig geklärt ist, aber.
Wenn man schon eine Immunität hat, also auch eine Immunität natürlich, die jetzt durch einen Impfstoff ausgelöst ist.
Dann ist es sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass diese neue äh Variante dann irgendeiner Form sich dran vorbeimogelt. Nicht komplett, aber,
Zumindest zu derzeitigen Zeitpunkt ähm ist es alles noch nicht so wild und man kann weiterhin davon ausgehen, dass diese Impfung noch lange halten.
Vor eine äh Sache noch, weil ich mich damit zufällig auch,
etwas näher beschäftigt hatte bei dem die sagen Attackrade in
bei der B eins eins sieben Variante altersabhängig, also es wurde ja.
Die die Aussage stand ja im Raum äh B eins eins sieben ist gefährlicher für Kinder.
So, ja. Das ist jetzt allerdings Erläuterungsbedürftig. Äh und zwar.
Ist es jetzt nicht so, äh dass jetzt.
Der B eins eins sieben Virus für Kinder gefährlicher ist als Erwachsene oder Kinder sich leichter anstecken mit dieser Variante als Erwachsene, sondern wenn man,
die klassische Variante vergleicht.
Und äh die B eins eins sieben Variante und dann guckt wie groß ist die Differenz zwischen.
Beiden äh so und das macht man, indem man eben äh die Fälle pro äh Kontakt äh.
Ermittelt, das haben in den halt in den UK, äh, in hauptsächlich gemacht, dass man geguckt hat bei Leuten, die erkrankt sind,
wie viele Kontakte haben die jetzt angegeben? Hatten sie in der Zeit so und.
Dann hat man lang verglichen wie viel Kontakte hatten Leute,
an der alten und wie viel an der neuen Variante erkrankt sind,
und dann hat man festgestellt, dass halt äh die Leute, die am B eins eins sieben erkrankt sind,
weniger Kontakte hatten, als die, die an der alten Variante erkrankt sind. Das heißt, es brauchte weniger Kontakte.
Krank zu werden, so. Und das hat man dann auch, weil man,
genug Fälle hatte, hat man eben nach Altersgruppen aufgeschlüsselt und hatte dann so ungefähr hundert Fälle pro Altersgruppe, das ist so die Genauigkeit, also,
jetzt Infektionen und dann ungefähr, weil nicht fünfzehn bis fünfundzwanzig Kontakte oder so pro äh Infektion.
Oder pro infizierten in den in den Gruppen und äh da zeigt sich das schon.
Grundsätzlich eher also Kinder.
Mehr Kontakte brauchen, um sich anzustecken, aber sagen in der neuen Variante.
Bisschen weniger mehr Kontakte brauchen. So und zwar vierundvierzig Prozent weniger mehr Kontakte
brauchen während andere Altersgruppen äh liegt es halt im Bereich von dreißig Prozent, wobei
sie halt auch zwei verschiedene Datenbasen, eine die sie im Zusammenhang mit dem mit der Gensequenzierung hatten,
eine, äh, die sie in zusammen ausgewählt hatten im Zusammenhang jetzt mit PCA Tests, äh wo erkannt worden ist, dass es der ein oder andere Virus ist und,
Ähm ich habe das dann auch mal visualisiert und da sieht man, dass es sozusagen in beiden Studien ungefähr,
ähnlich aussieht, aber dass das Ganze auch natürlich, weil das wieder Prozentzahlen von Prozentzahlen sind, schon mit einer gewissen Ungenauigkeit behaftet, aber grundsätzlich ist es so.
Ja äh dass,
das äh B eins eins sieben äh Virus äh ja bei Kindern mehr Vorteile hat äh als bei Erwachsenen im Vergleich der beiden Virusvarianten.
Okay.
Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall nochmal so im Blick behalten, aber bisher gab's jetzt noch nicht so sehr viel neues dazu. Zumindest habe ich nicht so viel Neues wahrgenommen, was jetzt wirklich den,
Stempel neu äh verdient hätte.
Wer denn noch der Meinung ist, Ruvit neunzehn wäre vielleicht gar nicht so problematisch, gibt da eine neue
die bei Netto rauskam und da haben sie wohl irgendwie festgestellt, dass so saß zwei das Virus, also die dadurch ausgelöste Krankheit, viel mehr äh nicht so geil ist fürs Sperma.
Ja, weil ähm auch da wohl eine ganze Menge ACE zwei Rezeptoren am Start sind und äh wenn man also
ja, sich auf eine Art und Weise infiziert, dass eben das Virus auch in diese Bereiche vordringt, dann ist es nicht so schön
denn bei starken, schweren Fällen
also gesehen, dass eben diese sogenannten Urkeimzellen davon betroffen sind und die Urkeimzellen sind diejenigen, die dann Spermien äh machen. Also.
Weitere Gründe sehe ich nicht unbedingt zu infizieren, wenn man es vermeiden kann. So, jetzt haben wir lange Sendung, jetzt vielleicht vielleicht noch,
Kleines Kunstprojekt nennen, zum Schluss.
Äh falls ihr den ganzen Irrsinn eh schon nicht mehr ertragt, gibt hier so ein äh kleines Online äh Ding, der Corona TV Bot.
Und das wenn man sich ein bisschen verwirren lassen will, ist das irgendwie ganz geil. Das sind irgendwie nichts anderes als irgendwie so ein, so ein, so ein,
neunzehn saß Koff zwei Scraper, der die ganze Zeit auf YouTube nach irgendwelchen Fernsehsendungen weltweit sucht, wo in irgendeiner Form dieses Thema.
Gegriffen wird und wenn man die Webseite aufmacht, dann
hat man irgendwie am laufenden Meter so ein Zyklus, also da spielt dann die Dinger immer eine Weile an und dann springt er wieder zum nächsten, das Ganze wird dann noch irgendwie übermalt mit tausend Tweets und was nicht alles, was gerade noch zu diesem Thema umgeht, also dieser ganze Overkill, dem idealen Ausstreuung, dieses Themas weltweit
Und wenn man das dann irgendwie mal so eine Weile laufen lässt, das hat, hat irgendwie schon so einen gewissen ästhetischen Reiz.
Alle möglichen Berichte aus was weiß ich wo äh her und siehst du auch mal wie unterschiedlich das Ganze auch so gecovert wird wo von ganzen Bild.
Ist Kunst.
Ja, interessant, klick, klicke ich mal äh an äh ja, ist bestimmt auch bunt.
Ist sehr bunt. Ist Kunst. Ja, Pavel, das bringt uns als Ende dieser Sendung, würde ich meinen.
War jetzt wieder ziemlich vollgepackt.
Wir bleiben weiter Verhalten optimistisch, dass es schon noch äh Wege gibt äh aus dieser Krise heraus und ich denke, die große Hoffnung liegt,
derzeit in der positiven Entwicklung der Verimpung. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass wir da Fortschritte sehen werden in der nächsten Zeit und wenn wir uns ansonsten ein bisschen am Riemen reißen.
Dann können wir ab Ostern vielleicht wieder Land sehen. Vorher allerdings glaube ich nicht, dass dass da viel gehen wird.
Denn so die Erkenntnis, dass so wie bisher irgendwie Salami-Taktik,
halt nirgendwo hinführt, dass wir jetzt dann doch nochmal irgendwie einen zweiwöchigen oder dreiwöchigen,
richtig harten Loktown kriegen,
das könnte die Sache dann vielleicht etwas beschleunigen wobei man eben auch sehen kann so da.
Dann nicht viel Zeit für Lockerung, also man muss das dann weiter
extrem im Auge behalten, ne. Er hat so viele Beispiele, wo innerhalb von zwei oder drei Wochen nicht aufgepasst äh so und äh dann ist in irgendeinem Land
die Zahlen komplett durch die Decke geschossen.
Irland, gutes Beispiel gerade.
Also kannst äh oder ich meine, gut Tschechien haben wir ja auch gesehen, du kannst durch eine Phase äh,
perfekt durchkommen und äh wenn du dann, wenn's dann äh wieder aufkocht und,
passt nicht auf, so. Ich meine, wir haben's ja auch so halb erlebt so, ja, da haben wir, sind ja auch,
um ein so vielfaches, schlechter haben wir jetzt die zweite Welle gehandelt als die erste.
Ja in jeder Hinsicht insofern ja hoffen wir mal, dass also so Hoffnung besteht, dass,
diese Erkenntnis jetzt in so viele politische Köpfe auch eingesickert ist, dass jetzt vielleicht man sich dann doch entscheidet, was zu tun, was auch hilft.
Oder was nachhaltig hören sie.
So Leute, das war's von uns hier äh von Corona Wickly und ähm ich denke.
Damit können wir euch ins Wochenende entlassen oder wann auch immer ihr äh das hört. Das war's heute von UKW. Wir sagen tschüss.
Ja nächste Woche hören wir uns wieder. Bis bald.